[Musique]
Delphine Bateau, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons en direct sur une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Alors, j'ai 46 ans, je suis militante
écologiste,
actuellement députée des Deux Sèvres
et présidente de Génération écologie.
Ancien ministre. ancienne ministre
de l'écologie
de l'écologie du développement durable
et de l'énergie de juin 2012 à juillet
2013.
Ça s'est bien passé quand vous étiez
là-bas ?
Il y a des choses qui se sont bien
passées. Oui. La fin un peu moins.
Pourquoi la fin ?
Parce que j'ai été limogé du
gouvernement pour avoir exprimé un
désaccord.
La politique, ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
encaisse ?
Non, je crois pas. Non, je crois pas.
Enfin, en tout cas, quand on est engagé
en politique pour changer les choses, ce
qui est mon cas, non, ça ferme pas sa
gueule. Et
euh en fait, moi, j'ai une approche des
responsabilités et du pouvoir si on
parle de de l'exercice de fonction
gouvernementale comme étant un moyen
d'agir au service d'une cause pour
changer les choses, pas comme une fin en
soi en fait. Et donc et ben quand il y a
un problème et en l'occurrence il y en
avait un gros sur en fait la la place de
l'écologie dans ce qui était la
politique du gouvernement de de François
Hollande euh ça passait ou ça cassait ?
Et ça a cassé.
Ça a cassé parce que vous étiez
sous-financé avec un un ministère qui
n'était pas régalien qui avait pas la
capacité de s'exprimer ou ça ça a cassé
parce que vous vous êtes rendu compte
que mon ennemi c'est la finance. c'était
un peu pipo et que si on touchait la
finance, on pouvait pas toucher à
l'économie, à l'écologie, pardon.
Il y avait euh dès le départ, je pense,
toute une toute une
comment dire, un ensemble de questions
sur est-ce que ce gouvernement, il était
là pour mettre en œuvre un projet de
transformation ou pas. Bon euh avec tous
les débats qu'on a vu sur le CICE, sur
Florange et sur d'autres sur d'autres
sujets euh débat dans lequel j'ai pu
prendre part, défendre un certain nombre
de de positions, mais sur l'écologie,
pour moi, il se jouait vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental en fait.
C'est-à-dire, est-ce que euh c'était
considéré comme un département
ministériel parmi d'autres ou est-ce que
ça devenait une priorité réelle dans le
contexte dans lequel on est en 2012 ?
Et en fait voilà, où est-ce que c'est
cosmétique ? Et en fait l'arbitrage
budgétaire à un moment donné, il dit
tout d'une politique et en l'occurrence
le choix budgétaire qui était fait et
que c'était au ministère de l'écologie
qui était demandé le plus de coupes
budgétaire, c'est-à-dire exactement
l'inverse de ce qu'il fallait faire.
Plus que le ministère de la culture.
Oui.
Oui. Oui.
Extraordinaire.
En tout cas, pour la loi de finance, il
s'agissait de du projet de loi de
finance 2014. Donc c'était le ministère
auquel était demandé les plus fortes
coupes budgétaires. Globalement, tout ça
est quand même dans un contexte, si vous
voulez où ce ministère a été le plus
matraqué par les révisions générales des
politiques publiques successives où le
ministère de l'écologie en France, il a
perdu 15000 agents en 15 ans où quand on
prend par exemple très concrètement
aujourd'hui la situation de l'UBrisol et
qu'on se pose la question de ce qui
explique le laxisme de l'État, ce qui
explique une augmentation de 34 % en 2
ans des accidents dans les sites CVSO,
une diminution des contrôles qui sont
passés de 38 30000 à 18000. On ne peut
pas ne pas regarder la question des
moyens humains, des moyens techniques,
des moyens en ingénieur du ministère de
de l'écologie. On peut prendre l'exemple
de Météofance. Euh à Météofance, on
supprime des agents qui sont des
prévisionnistes météo pour les remplacer
par des soi-disant super calculateurs
qui n'auront jamais la capacité de faire
l'analyse fine d'une prévision
météorologique par rapport à une
situation localisée. Donc en fait pour
agir pour l'écologie, pour exercer les
compétences de l'État dans un contexte
où les problèmes vont s'aggraver et vont
empirer, il faut des moyens humains. Et
donc la question des moyens d'action du
ministère de l'écologie, c'est pas une
question qui est secondaire.
Vous comprenez que Nicolas Hul, il est
euh fondu un plomb, pété une durite et
qu'il soit parti en claquant la porte
cette année ?
Je crois pas du tout moi qu'il ait fondu
un plan ou pété une durite. Il a fait un
il a fait un choix euh il a fait un
choix politique parfaitement fondé et
parfaitement justifié. Et en fait son
exemple
confirme en fait que c'est pas que c'est
pas une c'est pas un problème de
ministère, c'est pas un problème de la
personne des ministres successifs, c'est
le problème de en fait la place de
l'écologie dans le projet politique de
ceux qui exercent les responsabilités et
qui ont été élus pour les exercer. Et en
fait, tant qu'on considère que c'est le
problème d'un des départements
ministériels, rien rien n'avancera.
et ce ministère se se heurtera
éternellement à ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses du pouvoir
et au fait que
au fur et à mesure en fait de
l'affaiblissement de l'État que je
décrivais pour le ministère de
l'écologie mais qu'on pourrait qu' on
pourrait étendre le propos et
généraliser euh en fait il y a une forme
d'externalisation
euh il y a une forme d'externalisation
vers des lobby privés, vers des
entreprises privées, vers de l'expert
privé qui dessaisit l'état de ses
capacités
euh d'action. On reviendra on reviendra
sur les questions de
lobby privé, de de lobby tout court. Euh
je voudrais vous poser une question,
mais c'est difficile de la formuler.
Est-ce que l'écologie est compatible
avec la croissance ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
parce qu'en fait la croissance euh
c'est l'indice de destruction de la
nature.
Donc en fait la croissance du PIB euh
elle est la mesure euh de la
consommation d'énergie.
Euh elle est la mesure de la destruction
des écosystèmes. C'està dire en fait
plus on consomme d'énergie, plus on
détruit de nature, plus ça fait monter
la croissance.
Donc non, la l'écologie et la croissance
ne sont pas compatibles ne sont pas
compatibles. Et donc à partir de là, ça
veut dire que tous les discours
politiques sur la croissance verte
ou les conceptions de l'écologie étant
vu comme si vous voulez un nouveau dans
une vision kinésienne étant vu comme un
nouveau relais de croissance en fait
et ben c'est totalement obsolète
par rapport à la réalité des limites
planétaires et par rapport au lien qui a
été largement démontré par par plein de
plein de gens. Parmi ceux d'ailleurs que
vous avez que vous avez reçu à Syerview,
euh le lien qu'il y a entre le la
consommation de pétrole et d'énergie
fossile et la croissance économique
parce que nous sommes une société de
transformant. Ouais.
Euh comment on fait alors pour
chambouler tout ça, changer ce modèle de
civilisation quand on se rend compte que
en face de nous, il y a des marchés
financiers avec des fonds de retraite
qui euh se capitalisent grâce au marché
financier, qui récupère d'argent comme
ça.
Si on leur dit "Bah là maintenant la
croissance est terminée,
c'est font les marchés se vautrent."
Euh donc c'est on a le choix entre la
peste et le choléra. C'est-à-dire que si
on ne le fait pas, si on ne reprend pas
la main sur cette croissance
sans filtre, sans sans frein,
on va se taper le mur écologique, le mur
de la réalité. Et si et si
on le fait, les marchés financiers se
vaut ou laissent la France
face à des vautours qui vont se gaver ?
Alors bon, d'abord il y a il y a quand
même une première question, c'est est-ce
que le plus important c'est les marchés
financiers ou c'est de rester vivant ?
Euh ensuite il y a une deuxième
il y a d'abord le fait de regarder la
réalité en face.
C'est quoi la réalité
? C'estàd Oui. Mais donc de savoir en
fait à quoi on est confronté parce que
sinon on part dans des débats où les
solutions seraient pire que la
trajectoire sur laquelle on est. La
trajectoire sur laquelle on est, c'est
une trajectoire d'effondrement au
pluriel. l'effondrement du vivant et de
la biodiversité, il est déjà là. Euh et
euh l'accélération du changement
climatique, elle est en train, bon on le
voit avec ce qui se passe en Australie
et cetera, elle est en train euh d'att
d'atteindre les proportions dramatiques
qui étaient prévues par les
scientifiques. On est dans la
réalisation, il y a eu un très bon
papier l'autre jour de
je crois que c'est monsieur Hette
qui montre à quel point si vous voulez
les prévisions scientifiques sur qui
date de la fin je crois des années 80
tout ça pourra être vérifié en temps
réel
sont parfaitement confirmés en fait par
les par les faits sur le changement
climatique. Donc ça ça menace le
caractère habitable par l'espèce humaine
de la plupart des territoires sur terre.
C'est c'est ça la situation dans
laquelle on est.
Donc maintenant, on revient au marché
financier. On est dans cette trajectoire
d'effondrement parce qu'on explose les
limites planétaires. Donc on doit
effectivement changer de modèle
économique pour revenir à un modèle où
on a une empreinte écologique neutre,
c'est-à-dire où chaque année, on ne
consomme pas davantage que ce que la
planète peutir. Comment on passe de la
situation d'aujourd'hui on explose les
limites planétaires au respect des
limites planétaires ? Et ben en fait
plus
on hérite d'un certain nombre de
d'années d'inaction et de non décision,
plus les mesures à prendre et les
changements à opérer sont rapides et
doivent entraîner pour certains secteurs
précis pour commencer des
dévalorisations d'actifs qui sont gérés
volontairement. On peut prendre
l'exemple des énergies fossiles, on peut
prendre l'exemple des pesticides. Il y a
des sujets par lesquels il va falloir
commencer, sur lequel il va falloir
assumer les conséquences et il va
falloir les assumer collectivement. Et
en fait, c'est la raison pour laquelle
lequel sujet où on va être obligé
d'assumer les conséquences de cette
inertie. Quand vous décidez,
quand on a fait de la de la
subordination de vote pendant des
années, je prends le cas d'un politique
qui fait de la subordnation de vote.
Vote pour moi, je suis le président de
la croissance, tout ira bien.
Comment on fait pour faire avaler euh
cette inertie à à à des gens qui ont pas
beaucoup d'argent, qui sont déjà en
précarité énergétique ? Comment comment
on leur fait comprendre que bon, on
s'est gavé pendant 35 ans, 40 ans,
c'était vachement bien et maintenant va
falloir serrer la ceinture. Mais je
crois que les gens l'ont parfaitement
compris et qu'en fait c'est l'inverse de
se serrer la ceinture.
C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on ne peut pas
y arriver sans un changement culturel
profond. Ce changement, il est à l'œuvre
aujourd'hui. Vous avez 72 % des Français
qui disent que le modèle économique
actuel est pas compatible avec la lutte
contre le changement climatique. 55 %
qu'il faut réduire drastiquement notre
consommation. Euh en fait le système, il
véhicule une idée qui est complètement
qui est complètement fausse, c'est qu'en
fait l'écologie euh
ce serait un besoin de de certaines
catégories sociales. Bon, moi je suis
pas pour une je suis pas pour une
écologie BCBG,
je suis pour l'écologie pour tous. Et en
fait, ce qui est rendu complètement
invisible dans notre société, c'est
l'ampleur des inégalités
environnementales. Qui subit en fait le
plus la dépendance aux énergies fossiles
? Qui habite à côté des sites ces
vaisseaux ? Qui a le plus d'enfants
asthmatiques parce que les logements
sont ceux qui sont les moins chers et
que les logements les moins chers sont
ceux qui sont situés le long des axes
routiers ? C'est les catégories
populaires et c'est les catégories
modestes. C'est pas les plus nantis dans
notre société. Donc euh ça c'est la
première ch mais je veux revenir sur le
cette notion en fait de changement
culturel avec euh avec François Ruffin.
On a proposé à l'Assemblée nationale euh
un amendement pour supprimer les
liaisons aériennes inutiles sur les vols
intérieurs. Donc pour supprimer euh
Paris-Marseille, Paris Lyon,
Paris-Bordeaux, toutes les villes qui
sont desservies par le TGV. En fait,
c'est euh une mesure assez simple,
considérée comme assez radicale.
Euh j'ai été moi-même surprise quand il
y a eu un sondage, alors on n'y est
absolument rien pour rien avec Rufin
dans l'existence de ce dans de ce
sondage sondage. 69 % des Français
d'accord avec cette mesure en fait.
C'est-à-dire que il faut pas avoir une
vision de la situation et de ce que les
gens sont euh sont prêts à faire ou à ne
pas faire ou à soutenir ou à ne pas
soutenir comme si on était dans une
situation statique et linéaire. Les
Français, ils ont vécu la canicule. Les
Parisiens par exemple au mois de juin,
ils ont vécu le fait que les gosses dans
un certain nombre d'immeubles allaient
dans les parkings souterrains pour pour
pouvoir jouer dans un espace où il y
avait un semblant de fraîcheur. C'est du
vécu ça. Vous avez eu 46°gr dans
l'héros. Donc en fait nous tous
et la société dans son ensemble, elle
est entrée dans une prise de conscience
depuis maintenant, on peut dater ça
depuis depuis 2 ans, qui est nouvelle
par rapport à la nécessité d'agir et par
rapport à la nécessité de changer nos
modes de vie. Et ce changement de nos
modes de vie, il est euh
de plus en plus vécu pas du tout comme
un sacrifice, mais comme un choix
positif. comme une libération en fait,
comme une émancipation. ceux qui vont
euh euh faire les courses, voyez, avec
pour prendre les trucs euh en vraque,
euh qui choisissent de ne plus avoir de
bouteille d'eau en plastique, euh qui au
wagon bar de la SNCF euh vont refuser
euh la touillette en plastique. Pour
prendre des exemples très simples en
fait, ils sont en fait dans des actes de
non consentement,
de reprise de pouvoir en fait par
rapport à au consumérisme, par rapport à
la société de consommation et ils le
vivent pas du tout comme un truc triste,
horrible, un renoncement. Il il y a en
fait fondamentalement dans ce qui est en
train de se passer un début de rupture
avec l'idéologie dominante où ce qui
compte euh c'est ce qu'on possède, c'est
d'avoir toujours plus d'argent. regarder
ce qui est en train de se passer chez
les Moi, j'ai fait pas mal de débats
dans les dans les universités ou dans
des écoles ces derniers temps. Et en
fait, c'est très frappant de voir que le
si vous voulez dans les années 80 euh
moi je suis de la génération qui était
ados dans les années 80, le modèle
dominant pour les jeunes qui allaient
faire des études, bon moi j'en ai pas
faite mais c'était de devenir cadre sup,
de bosser tous les jours jusqu'à 23h,
d'avoir un super gros salaire, de beau,
de beaucoup voyager dans le monde. Là,
c'est pas du tout ça. C'est "Je veux
avoir un travail qui a du sens. Je veux
bosser pour une entreprise euh qui euh
euh quand même a conscience des enjeux
du changement climatique. Je veux avoir
un travail super intéressant mais qui me
laisse un espace de vie pour ma vie
personnelle euh et pour avoir des liens
forts avec mes proches et m'occuper de
mes enfants. Je veux être pas trop loin
physiquement de mon boulot parce que je
veux pas me taper des heures de
transport. Et en fait quand on regarde
dans les détails, vous avez par exemple
aujourd'hui neuf français sur 10 qui
aspirent à ralentir dans leur vie
quotidienne.
Et les marchés financiers quand ils
ralentissent, il se passe quoi ?
Mais ils ralentissent aussi. Voilà, ils
ralentissent aussi. Et donc ça veut dire
que on est on est dans un changement
fondamental de ce qui est au centre de
la place du village. Ce qui est au
centre de la place du village
aujourd'hui dans notre société, c'est
l'argent.
Et là, on met au centre de la place du
village le vivant, le fait d'être en vie
et d'avoir des liens forts avec nos
proches, avec la nature. Donc, c'est
effectivement un changement total de
mythologie. Je sais pas si vous avez lu
il y a il y a un très bon bouquin de de
Stéphane Fouard qui s'appelle des
marchés des dieux qui fait le récit
comme ça de en fait comment cette
histoire de marché financier et cette
valeur cardinale de l'argent dans nos
sociétés, c'est de l'ordre, c'est devenu
de l'ordre de la religion en fait. Euh
on avait un débat à on avait un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale sur la loi sur le
sur le gaspillage là sur le sur
l'économie circulaire euh où le
gouvernement vient présenter son projet
de loi en disant euh alors c'était plus
pour la croissance verte mais c'était
pour le pour le découplage quoi. On est
de l'ordre si vous on est dans l'ordre
de la mystification totale c'est-à-dire
de choses qui ne représent qui ne
reposent pas sur des faits qui ne
reposent pas sur de la science
de la religion.
Oui, une forme de religion. Ouais. Forme
de croyance dans le fait que le bonheur
humain, il est indexé à la croissance
économique. Alors, on peut si on on on
regarde les rétroviseurs, en fait, c'est
il y a une espèce de nostalgie des
trendes glorieuses qu'aurait été l'âge
d'or qu'on chercherait éternellement à
retrouver. Alors, outre que cet âge d'or
euh en fait il comportait en lui tous
les germes de des chaos actuels, bon euh
on n'est plus du tout dans cette
situation là depuis depuis quoi 20 30
ans. Euh la pauvreté en France, elle a
augmenté de façon inédite au cours des
10 dernières années. L'année dernière,
on a eu 400000 pauvres en plus. Alors,
les chiffres du chômage diminuent, mais
400000 pauvres en plus. Donc on a et de
la croissance économique et une
augmentation des inégalités et des
canicules et une accélération du
changement climatique. Donc le fait de
lier le bien-être humain et la réduction
des inégalités à la croissance
économique, c'est quelque chose qui
n'est factuellement plus du tout vrai.
Et et le bonheur, parce que ça se
calcule, le bonheur, il y a un indice du
bonheur de l'OCDE, il a baissé de 10 %
en 10 ans. la consommation
d'antidépresseur, je pense c'est un
indicateur qui est intéressant. Elle a
été multipliée par 7 en 20 ans. Donc
c'est pas une société qui nous rend
heureux et épanoui. C'est pour ça qu'il
faut en changer.
Je reviens sur les marchés financiers.
Quand ils ralentissent, il se passe quoi
? Ils ralentissent juste
à court terme. Est-ce que leur dire vous
allez ralentir, ça va pas leur provoquer
un petit peu de stress ? Ils vont pas
nous faire un petit craque et ce petit
craque qui paye les fonctionnaires aux
États-Unis. Je pense que l'instabilité
qu'il y a aujourd'hui sur les marchés
financiers n'a pas besoin euh
pour se pour se révéler pour qui a comme
vous l'évoquez de possibles
nouvelles crises financières ou de
nouveaux craques. Euh qu'elle ait
nécessairement besoin que ça résulte
d'un programme écologire. Beaucoup
d'économistes décrivent l'instabilité
actuelle, le fait que pas grand-chose en
fait en réalité n'a été réglé après la
crise de 2008-2009. Donc l'instabilité,
elle est là, je veux dire intrinsèque
dans le dans le système.
Pour l'instant, on est on est en
apesanteur, tout se passe bien. Pourquoi
les embêter à leur demander de ralentir
? Est-ce qu'il va falloir attendre un
événement exogène, genre une tempête qui
flingue tous les assureurs ? Est-ce
qu'il va falloir attendre ça pour que
les marchés financiers comprennent que
le comportement prédateur sur
Ah non, c'est pire que ça parce que
enfin si vous prenez l'exemple de des
tempêtes, malgré l'augmentation du coup
des catastrophes naturelles,
je veux dire la mécanique du profit,
elle se met elle se met partout. Bon euh
y compris sur l'assurance des sur
l'assurance des catastrophes euh
naturelles. Donc ça rassurez-vous, ils
trouveront toujours des astuces pour
faire du pour faire du profit, même avec
des catastrophes. Non, il faut euh enfin
la vraie question si vous voulez, c'est
euh un pouvoir écologiste qui vous qui
veut vraiment réussir et accomplir une
transformation de la société dans cette
direction. Comment il s'y prend ? Quelle
résistance il va devoir affronter ? Donc
oui, il va devoir
quelle méthode
et quelle méthode ? Donc c'est oui, il
va devoir affronter la résistance des
marchés financiers et oui, il faut un
programme méthodique qui permet si si
vous voulez, c'est c'est ce que
j'essayais d'évoquer tout à l'heure,
c'est-à-dire de
dans les mesures à mettre en place de
définir des priorités qui sont claires.
Voilà, la priorité claire c'est la
sortie des énergies fossiles.
Deuxième priorité claire, c'est la santé
et la biodiversité et donc c'est la
sortie totale de l'agriculture chimique.
Voilà les deux priorité clair où à
partir de là vous êtes pas si vous
voulez dans une logique d'affrontement
avec tous les acteurs économiques dans
tous les domaines mais vous avez sériez
précisément ce que vous voulez faire. Et
si on reprend l'exemple des énergies
fossiles pour ce qui concerne la France,
euh on a à la fois aujourd'hui une
urgence euh qui est lié au climat euh
mais on a euh une urgence dans la sortie
des énergies fossiles qui est liée aux
conséquences sociales de l'augmentation
du prix du pétrole
et qui est lié
à
la dépendance géostratégique
qu'induit le fait que la principale
énergie consommé en France, soit du soit
du pétrole avec toutes les conséquences.
non seulement sur la balance commerciale
euh mais aussi sur notre dépendance
vis-à-vis d'un certain nombre de de
régions du monde.
On on on va on va reparler de l'énergie
après et on va parler s'il faut du
nucléaire, pas du nucléaire pour cette
transition
ou du moins ce cet atterrissage.
Euh quand on voit que il y a une unité
de gendarmerie qui a été fondée pour
surveiller les écologistes,
c'est bien, c'est pas bien ? Est-ce
qu'il s'attendent à des mouvements
violents ? Est-ce qu'ils s'attendent à
des mouvements non violents mais qui
pourraient être contre-productifs pour
l'économie,
leur économie ? Qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire de voir l'État
créer des macrophages pour repérer ce
qu'il considère comme des tumeurs ?
Alors, d'abord, moi je suis pour la non
violence.
Je considère que on ne peut pas
défendre un idéal d'une société qui est
en harmonie avec la nature et en
harmonie entre les humains par des
méthodes d'action violentes. Et cette
question là me paraît absolument
fondamentale particulièrement en France.
Donc
il faut faire quoi ? Des greffes de la
fin ? Non, mais je pense je pense que
c'est pardonnez-moi, mais très important
de d'abord savoir tout le son du 20e
siècle, c'est que tous ceux qui pensé au
nom d'un idéal, si vous voulez agir avec
des méthodes de alors je mets de côté
quand on est dans la résistance, que les
nazis sont au pouvoir et cetera, hein,
mais le reste du temps, ça c'est quand
même en général toujours mal fini. Donc
on ne défend pas des idées
justes par des méthodes d'action.
violente dans une société qui est une
société démocratique. On pourrait y
revenir si vous voulez. Ça c'est
fondamental.
Et donc moi je ne considère pas comme
des écologistes
des personnes qui ont des méthodes
d'action violentes. Je pense que ceux
qui ont des méthodes d'action violentes
sont les idiots utiles du système en
fait. que quand on regarde par exemple
ce qui comment ça se fait que les
manifes de jeunes pour le climat sont
massives dans un certain nombre de pays
et moins en France, c'est pas parce que
les jeunes français ils se sentiraient
moins concernés qu'à Bruxelles, qu'à
Lausanne ou je ne sais où ou qu'à
Montréal, c'est qu'il y a ce problème
dans les manifestations de de
l'intervention d'un certain nombre
d'individus euh qui mettent un climat
qui fait qu'on a pas envie en fait de
venir à la manifestation. Si eux
considèrent le pouvoir en face comme une
autre forme de nazisme
économique, est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous pouvez les comprendre aussi ? Non,
je pense que c'est vraiment les alors là
euh
les idiots du système, je pense c'est
pas du tout euh ce qu'on pourrait
considérer, je sais pas moi, par
exemple, comme les les enfants
turbulents de l'écologie, c'est pas du
tout ça. Et je pense qu'il joue un rôle
euh contre-productif
qui rend éminemment service en fait au
tenant du statut coc Shepard
et au tenant du système. Si je fais
part, c'est autre chose et donc je ne
mets pas dans ce que je suis en train de
dire, je ne vise pas la radicalité, je
ne vise pas la désobéissance civile, je
vise la violence en tant que telle.
Alors maintenant, je reviens à la
question sur la l'histoire de la cellule
d'émèire
que la gendarmerie
extraordinaire des métaires d'ailleurs
Ouais. que la gendarmerie, oui, en
référence à la mythologie, que la
gendarmerie, si vous voulez, euh lutte
contre des actions violentes,
par exemple, je sais pas visant, il y a
eu les boucheries euh
c'est et contre des actes de
délinquence,
c'est une chose. Mais ce qui est très
perturbant dans le dispositif là qui a
été annoncé, c'est que ça concerne aussi
les
discours idéologique de critique du
modèle agricole. Là, on est et là, on
est dans on est dans autre chose en
fait. Donc, il y a une dans le
dispositif qui a été annoncé par le
ministre de l'intérieur euh avec en plus
un truc quand même bizarre qui est la
convention cignée par le ministre de
l'intérieur et deux organisations
syndicales agricoles. Pas avec les
chambres d'agriculture, pas avec les
institutions du monde agricole, avec
deux organisations syndicales du monde
agricole. C'est cette confusion qu'il y
a entre des actes de délinquence que
tout le monde peut réprouver ou
condamner et des actions militantes et
un discours militant
dénonçant, je sais pas moi, les
pesticides,
l'absence de mesures de protection des
riverins,
les mines de charbon,
pardon ?
Les mines de charbon ?
Non, c'est pas dans cette c'est pas dans
c'est pas dans Desémre.
Non, c'est pas dans Desém. Ouais,
je demande à la communauté de fa checker
mais si des se prend du sujet que tous
les gens qui viennent s'enchaîner des à
des rail pour empêcher le nucléaire de
passer ou d'empêcher les mines de
charbon de fonctionner
non desire la cellule démétaire elle
vise que ce qui concerne le monde
agricole.
C'est ça qui a été annoncé, hein.
C'est ce qui a été annoncé par le
ministre de l'intérieur.
Euh donc c'est autre chose.
D'accord. Si si pour vous c'est un
délinquant celui qui s'enchaîne à des
voix ferrées ou pas ?
euh formellement, juridiquement, on est
plus dans des actions de désobéissance
civile. Mais devant un juge, c'est quoi
devant un juge, bah vous avez par
exemple actuellement les portraits de de
ceux qui ont décroché
voilà décrocher les
portraits euh d'Emmanuel Macron ou où
dans les mairies où vous avez euh par
exemple le jugement qui a été rendu en
Suisse euh qui est très intéressant
aussi qui euh reconnaît que l'action qui
a été menée c'est une action destinée à
alerter en fait les autres les autres
citoyens ou les pouvoirs publics sur
pour l'urgence d'agir pour le pour
l'écologie.
Si Shepard,
donc je mets pas du tout sur le même
plan si vous voulez des actes des actes
de destruction, des actes d'agression
envers les biens ou envers les
personnes, que ce soit de la violence
verbale ou de la violence physique et
des actes de désobéissance civile.
Si pard quoi ? C'est violent, c'est pas
violent, c'est légitime, c'est
illégitime, c'est légal,
je considère, je considère pas que ce
soit violent.
de de s'oppose de se mettre en travers
d'un
bateau qui va aller harponner des
séassés. Non, je considère pas que ce
soit de la violence
et d'aller le couler.
En l'occurrence dans l'histoire, c'est
pas c'est pas les écologistes qui ont
qui ont coulé des bateaux.
Est-ce qu'il faut que ça généralise des
choses comme ça ? Qu'on soit plus
proactif ?
Alors, je moi je crois que la priorité
c'est surtout de massifier les
mobilisation,
c'est-à-dire que le nombre de personnes
qui s'engagent, le nombre de personnes
qui participent à des marches pour le
climat ou à des actions soit beaucoup
plus importants. Et donc c'est le
problème aussi qui est posé avec la
violence et avec des mots d'ordre qui
quelque part échappent euh à ceux qui
euh euh sont à l'initiative en fait de
ces mobilisations, qui sont des mots
d'ordre plaqués par des fractions
politiques en réalité très organisé euh
qui viennent là pour recruter, qui
viennent là pour radicaliser et qui donc
décisent les mobilisations écologistes
de leur autonomie, de leur propre mot
d'ordre et de leur indépendance
politique parce qu'en en fait une une
mobilisation qui peut se développer, qui
peut être extrêmement puissante. C'est
une mobilisation
qui n'appartient qu'à ceux qui la
conduisent en fait et qui est pas dans
une logique d'instrumentalisation
politique. Quand je vais par exemple à
une euh je sais pas une marche pour le
climat si vous voulez et que je et que
je vois crier de but en blanc comme ça
anti anticapitaliste, je me je me dis il
y a un truc qui cloche en fait. Voilà.
Et je suis sûre qu'il y a plein de gens
pour qui c'est la première manifestation
qui viennent parce que euh ils sont euh
euh très choqué euh par la canicule, par
la fonte euh de la banquise euh qui
trouvent scandaleux que le gouvernement
fasse rien, euh qu'ils ont été révoltés
par la démission de Nicolas Hullot. si
vous voulez au point de départ, il
n'arrivent pas avec un niveau de
conscience qui leur permettrait de
rejoindre spontanément
un slogan anti anticapitaliste, même si
évidemment qu'il y a un problème avec le
capitalisme, c'est pas le sujet. Donc ça
ça me paraît la priorité absolue en fait
d'élargir la puissance des mobilisations
et de leur de leur donner une
perspective politique. Voilà, ça c'est
plus le travail que j'essaie de auquel
j'essaie de contribuer.
Vous trouvez qu'il y a des des
mouvements écologiques qui sont très
sectaires ?
Je suis contre le sectarisme moi. Donc
je suis pas là pour donner des bons
points ou des ou des mauvais points. Je
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est exactement
l'inverse qu'il faut faire. En fait, il
faut il faut être majoritaire
dans le pays. Il faut être complètement
majoritaire. Et donc il faut être plus
nombreux, il faut être ouvert, il faut
être l'inverse du sectarisme. Il faut
être joyeux, enthousiasment
ce qu'on a ce qu'on sent d'ailleurs dans
les manifestations de de jeû enfin je
sais pas si vous avez vu les pancarts,
toute la créativité qu'il y a, le
l'intelligence des slogans, le niveau
d'éducation, le niveau d'information euh
qui est qui est qui est quelque chose de
d'extrêmement positif. C'est quand même
la nouvelle, à mes yeux, la nouvelle
politique la plus importante au cours de
l'année et demi qui vient de s'écouler,
l'émergence d'un mouvement international
de la jeunesse
face à l'urgence écologique. C'est la
meilleure nouvelle de la parler Gr.
Après, j'ai une question internet de
Zatopec.
Croit-elle que la Z de Notream des
Landes aurait aurait si bien tenu sans
sa frange violente dans les manifes à
Nantes ? Et bien moi je crois
vous avez été à Notream des Landes
non mais
très
j'ai un point de vue différent
mon point de vue donc je parle pas de
l'occupation illégale du site hein je
parle des agissements extrêmement
violents
et bien je pense exactement l'inverse.
C'est qu'il faut se pren
je crois que sans ces problèmes de
violence, il y aurait certainement eu
une manifestation d'un million de
personnes en France pour l'abandon de
l'aéroport de Notreame des Landes.
à un moment donné qu'à un moment donné
les pouvoirs successifs et les
gouvernements successifs et j'en ai vu
certains de près était dans le fait de
tenir à Notre Dame des Landes pour des
raisons pour des raisons d'ordre public
parce qu'il ne pouvait pas être question
de céder à la violence et plus du et
plus enfin ça n'avait plus aucun sens
par rapport à l'histoire de l'aéroport
lui-même si vous voulez. De la même
façon, il se raconte et je pense que
c'est un point très important. J'ai
entendu des débats dans lesquels on me
disait "Ouais mais regardez les gilets
jaunes, ils ont obtenu des choses par la
violence". Ben non, en fait, ils ont
rien obtenu les gilets jaunes.
Les gilets jaunes sont pas violents,
hein.
Non, les groupes qui dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes,
pas les gilets jaunes,
donc pas les gilets jaunes, vous avez
tout à fait raison. Donc les groupes qui
allaient à l'occasion des manifestations
des gilets jaunes cassés et cetera et
cetera.
Comment nommez-les ces groupesci ?
C'était quoi ? Ils avaient une
revendication, ils avaient des noms ces
groupesl comment ils s'appellent ? Ah
ben c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je vois des graffitis de l'extrême
droite et des anarchistes les uns à côté
des autres. Euh ça m'a frappé.
Ça disait quoi ?
C'est très inquiétant.
Et ça disait quoi ?
Ben ça disait qu'il y a des qu'il y a
des des passerelles en train de se
construire qui son
le graffiti avait marqué quoi sur le
graphe ?
Oh, je m'en souviens plus. Enfin, il y
avait les sigles. Il y avait les sigles.
C'était quoi le sigle ? Ben, c'était un
truc qui ressemblait fou euh au sigle du
Gud ou un truc comme ça et euh le a euh
l'un euh à côté de l'autre. Bon, enfin
bref, euh
est-ce que le mouvement des gilets
jaunes euh il aurait en quelque sorte
bénéficié en fait de ces de ces
agissements violents ? Moi, je pense que
c'est exactement l'inverse.
Alors que
peut-être pour ça qu'on a on a laissé
ces groupes infiltrer les gilets jaunes.
C'est possible.
C'est possible. Mais moi, je n'en ai pas
de je n'en ai pas de preuve euh
que
euh
le ministère de l'intérieur par rapport
à tous ces agissements violents euh
par quoi du LBD là ? Non, non, non, non,
non, non. Je parle par rapport à euh qui
sont les casseurs en fait. Euh que ce
soit pendant les manifestations des
gilets jaune ou que ce soit dans les
manifestations euh comme celle de
septembre dernier pour la marche, pour
le climat, euh que le ministère de
l'intérieur sache à qui on a affaire et
ne fasse rien, c'est une possibilité. Je
n'en ai aucune preuve. Donc je peux pas
être affirmative sur une sur une
affirmation comme celle-là parce que en
fin de compte
ce serait pas plus mal que les
manifestations dégénèrent comme ça elles
sont moins populaires.
Voilà. En tout état de cause. Euh ce que
je pour revenir à ça, je voulais cacher
casser la légende selon laquelle le fait
qu'il y ait des violences pendant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes aurait
permis à ce mouvement de gagner sur ses
revendications. Je pense que c'est
exactement l'inverse. Et d'ailleurs, si
aujourd'hui on regarde qu'est-ce qu' a
obtenu en fait fondamentalement le
mouvement des gilets jaunes à part
l'abandon de l'augmentation de la taxe
carbone, il y a rien. Il y a rien. Quand
quand l'Arc de Triomphe s'est s'est vu
ner h
et que des gilets jaunes se sont
retrouvés nassés, ça a été très violent.
Euh euh de souvenir euh le patronat
avait appelé Macron pour dire "Tu lâches
tout, tu lâches tout parce que là euh ça
sent la fourche." Donc pas de violence.
Je repose la question qui était au
départ sur Notre Dame des Landes.
Sur Notre Dame des Landes répondu
aurait si bien tenu son sa franche
violente dans les manies fanantes.
Mais moi je je pense que cette bataille
aurait pu être gagnée plus vite et plus
tôt.
Comment ?
Par c'est toujours le même. Une petite
fleur dans la bouche, on chante
ensemble. Non, je pense qu'il pouvait y
avoir il pouvait y avoir il pouvait y
avoir d'abord je crois pas qu'en
démocratie on impose son point de vue
par la force vraiment et par la
violence. Euh et ensuite encore une fois
je pense que
quand vous avez envie d'aller à une
manife en famille parce que vous trouvez
la cause sympa et cetera, ben en fait si
vous savez qu'il y a des casseurs et
qu'il va y avoir des problèmes, vous y
allez pas. C'est aussi simple que ça. Et
donc en fait la violence, elle aboutit à
isoler et à minorer le nombre de
personnes prêtes à s'engager pour
soutenir une cause. C'est son seul
résultat.
Voilà. Donc non, je ne je ne considère
pas que
la la
violence et la force des faibles et
commence où s'arrêtent les
connaissances. On aura compris
en tout cas dans
euh l'état actuel de la démocratie
française. Je dirais pas ça euh si on
était dans une dictature dans l'état
actuel de la démocratie française. Il y
a aucune raison où on a accès à la
liberté d'expression, à la liberté de
manifestation. Il y a aucune raison de
penser qu'on fait avancer le chemil blic
par la violence. C'est même l'inverse.
On va parler de la démocratie française.
H
Donc, on est toujours en démocratie, on
n'est pas en dictature.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce qui vous alerterait pour vous
? Quel est le la ligne de non retour ?
C'est quoi ? C'est que
c'est une démocratie.
Il a tous les médias qui disent la même
chose au même moment. C'est une c'est
une c'est une démocratie
de façade
dans laquelle le problème posé et qu'il
y a une sorte de de souveraineté cachée
en fait euh qui euh qui est celle de
l'influence
d'un certain nombre de grands groupes.
Euh bon, c'est la résultant de de tout
ce qui s'est passé depuis
les années 80. tout ça mélangé
euh un certain nombre de structures
fondamentales de de l'État, mais qui
fait que aujourd'hui une des raisons
fondamentales qui explique ben par
exemple le mouvement des gilets jaunes
et qui explique ce sentiment qu'ont
beaucoup de Français que les
gouvernements passent mais les problèmes
restent qui mènent tous à peu près la
même politique, c'est qu'en fait dans
les arrières-cuisines
euh c'est les mêmes influences.
Et c'est quoi ces influences ? c'est
l'influence euh de de
des lobby et de leur relation avec la
très haute fonction publique.
et ce qui s'est mis en place
dans notre pays en terme de
alors moi j'appelle ça une je assez loin
parce que je parle de corruption
culturelle en fait de la haute fonction
publique
c'est-à-dire une perte complète de ce
qu'est le sens de l'État l'éthique de
l'État le sens de l'intérêt général et
donc ce qu'est la différence entre
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt des
entreprises privées il arrive
que les intérêts de la France et les
intérêts de telle ou telle entreprise
privée convergent.
Mais il y a aussi plein de situations
dans lesquelles ce n'est pas le cas. Et
alors en particulier dès que vous êtes
sur des enjeux écologiques ou sur des
enjeux de santé publique et ben il y a
il y a il y a contradiction entre ce qui
qu'est l'intérêt de telle ou telle
grande entreprise et ce qu'est l'intérêt
public, l'intérêt général. Et euh là, il
y a tout un tissu de d'entre soi, de
copains de promo, de dîner en ville
et ce système de gestion des des
carrières euh avec les les le
pantouflage, les allers-retours dans le
secteur privé et cetera euh qui organise
en fait la la congélation euh des
décisions. On en a ces derniers jours
des exemples mais complètement
spectaculaires. Euh
on écoute. Alors, on a par exemple Total
et l'huile de palme.
Donc, le groupe Total qui est quand même
pas à plaindre du point de vue financier
euh veut à tout prix euh
que la France revienne sur le vote du
Parlement, mettant fin à la niche
fiscale de 70 millions d'euros par an
euh pour l'importation d'huile de palme,
donc qui entraîne la déforestation de
l'Indonésie, la mort des Orang Outant et
cetera pour l'usine de LAAM.
euh pour la bioraffinerie de de la MEDE.
Bioraffinerie.
Bon, on est dans le dans le voyez dans
le green washing des appellations. Euh
donc, il y a eu un vote du Parlement.
Euh lors de la dernière loi de finance,
vous avez un député euh qui a présenté
un amendement pour rétablir la niche
fiscale.
Quel député ?
Euh, monsieur Lakila. Euh députés des
Buches du Rône, euh députés ben faut
pour moi modem ou la République en
marche euh plutôt la République en
marche. Non, c'est pas la même chose
parce que c'est un député du Modem qui a
mené le combat contre le contre le
contre cette niche fiscale justement,
monsieur Milien. Et euh donc
l'amendement est passé en fait comme une
lettre à la poste parce que si vous
voulez dans l'hémicycle euh il l'a pas
présenté, c'està-dire il a juste dit
défendu. Donc comme ça il était même pas
question de
savoir qu'est-ce qui était en train
d'être voté. Donc évidemment euh
les députés s'en sont rendus compte, il
y a eu un nouveau vote et la niche
fiscale a été de nouveau supprimé. Donc
et on apprend donc normalement fin de
l'épisode et on apprend que le
gouvernement a adressé une note des
douanes qui considère euh qu'un produit
euh est en fait un sous-produit de
l'huile de palme qui donc il doit être
considéré au titre de l'économie
circulaire et qu'à ce titre-là, il n'est
pas concerné par la suppression de la
niche fiscale et par le statut fiscal de
de l'huile de palme.
Voilà. Donc quand la porte est fermée,
on passe par la fenêtre. Quand la
fenêtre est fermée, on passe par le trou
de la serrure. C'est la note des
douanes, vous voyez, pour contester en
fait le vote du parlement. Et il y a un
nouvel exemple qui qui a été publié hier
qui concerne ce qu'a voté le parlement
pour interdire
ouver en plastique,
non, pour interdire la fabrication en
France de pesticides
interdits en France.
Euh par exemple, la trasine est
interdite en France depuis très
longtemps. C'est un pesticide
extrêmement dangereux dont on trouve
encore des traces dans l'eau de nos
rivières. Et en fait, il
il y a encore en France des fabrications
d'atrasin pour l'exporter notamment en
Afrique. Et en fait, il y a eu un vote
de l'Assemblée nationale euh de bon
sens, c'est de dire quand c'est pas chez
nous, c'est pas ailleurs non plus. Et
donc on va pas accepter que la France
fabrique et exporte des produits qui
sont notoirement dangereux au point
qu'ils ont été interdits en France. Et
là aussi euh il y a même une lettre qui
a été révélée par le monde hier de
l'Élysée qui dit qu'il comprennent tout
à fait l'inquiétude des fabricants de
pesticides, qu'ils vont trouver une
solution pour que le la décision du
parlement ne s'applique pas. J'ouvre une
parenthèse, un commentaire de la
communauté qui dit "Bonjour, peut-elle
nous expliquer comment la non violence
et son dogme ont permis toutes les
avances sociales ? C'est elle comment
Nelson Mandela, Gandy et d'autres ont
réussi leur combat ?
Peut-être devrait-elle lire ce très bon
livre ? Comment la non violence protège
l'État ?
Justement,
c'est très étonnant de citer Gandy et
Nelson Mandela
qui sont qui sont des références euh en
la matière. Donc je je sais pas, je
trouve ça un peu curieux comme comme
point de vue en fait pour aller plus
loin dans ce que je disais sur cette ça
m'étonne pas que ça fasse débat et
pourtant je persiste et je signe.
Non seulement je suis contre la
violence, c'est pas du tout mon idéal de
de je déteste la violence même, je peux
dire, mais en plus je suis
j'ai une claire conscience en fait euh
de la difficulté de l'exercice du
pouvoir. C'estàd que vraiment en fait
aujourd'hui pour les écologistes, je
considère, je vais peut-être surprendre
par ce que je vais dire que le plus dur
n'est pas de gagner les élections. Le
plus dur, c'est de réussir la
transformation écologique du pays. Et en
fait, ça, vous ne pouvez le faire que si
vous avez une assise, que si vous avez
une société mobilisée, que si vous
continuez en fait la bataille
culturelle. Et on me frappe à croire
qu'on mène la bataille culturelle pour
se débarrasser du consumérisme, pour se
débarrasser des rapports de domination
des humains sur la nature, des hommes
sur les femmes, de certains peuples sur
d'autres et cetera, par des méthodes
d'action violentes. Je suis désolée mais
c'est exactement l'inverse en fait de ce
qu'on veut faire et des idées qu'on
défend. Donc euh pour porter une
cause euh il faut lui il il faut lui il
faut lui ressembler.
Bien, on fait pas si on vit si on vit au
présent, si vous avez aujourd'hui des
méthodes d'action violentes, c'est que
vous êtes dans une logique de rapport de
domination en fait et c'est que vous
êtes aussi dans une pratique qui n'est
pas celle d'accepter la diversité, qui
n'est pas d'accepter la différence des
points de vue. Bon, c'est antinomique en
fait avec ce que doit être une société
démocratique accomplie.
Donc il faut changer la France, faut
arriver que la France que la France
arrive à à changer son modèle.
Il y a pas de raccourci en fait par
rapport à la nécessité de construire une
majorité politique pour changer les
choses.
Comment on fait à l'échelle mondiale mis
à part Greta qui fait la grève scolaire
? Comment on fait pour faire comprendre
aux Chinois que culturellement parlant,
bon ça va 5 minutes ? Comment on fait
comprendre au continent africain que bah
il faut qu'on marche tous ensemble ?
Qu'est-ce que les Africains ? Qu'est-ce
que les Chinois ? Qu'est-ce que les
Indiens, qu'est-ce que les Pakistanais
vont nous répondre ? quand on va leur
dire "Bon écoutez les cocos, maintenant
on serre un peu la ceinture, tout va
bien se passer. Votre idéal, ça fait 30
ans qu'on vous envoie de la pub, tout le
monde roule en Porsche, on a tous des PP
pépé.
D'abord qui qui on est,
qui qui on serait pour leur dicter
à ces peuples ?
Le FMI
non, qui on serait pour pour leur dicter
ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils ont à penser ou
ce qu'ils doivent faire ? Donc
moi je je suis pas du tout dans une
logique
si vous voulez où ou notre vision des
choses, notre modèle de une vision qui
serait en quelque sorte un peu
coloniale, qui en plus correspond plus
du tout à l'état du monde d'aujourd'hui
euh qui serait de dicter euh notre
vision des choses. Euh par contre, on
doit reprendre notre souveraineté.
Par contre, on doit reprendre notre
souveraineté. Et en fait euh
par rapport à qui ?
Par rapport à tout le monde,
vous
avez pas des cas précis ?
Euh notamment notamment aux Américains.
Euh on doit reprendre notre
souveraineté.
C'est possible encore.
Euh
en fait je pense que c'est évidemment
pas possible si on décrète que on ne
peut rien faire de toute façon. ce qui
est
le comment dire le l'attitude
euh
qui prévaut depuis un certain temps,
c'est en fait de ne même pas essayer.
C'est ça moi que je leur reproche. C'est
pas de dire "Ah ben finalement on a dû
faire un compromis et cetera." C'est
qu'en fait il y a même pas eu de
tentative de protéger notre souveraineté
énergétique. Alors notre souveraineté
numérique, j'en parle même pas. Euh il y
a jamais eu de volonté de tenter quoi
que ce soit. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est
notre souveraineté militaire en fait qui
est qui est atteinte. Euh donc
le propos pour moi n'est pas de dire
qu'il faut dicter à d'autres pays ce
qu'ils auraient à faire sur l'écologie,
c'est de mener la bataille pour et comme
on peut pas être dans une logique de
transformation écologique dans un seul
pays, on a la nécessité euh de
construire et d'avoir des alliés. Et le
ce qui est frappant si vous voulez,
c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui pour la
première fois un mouvement international
de la jeunesse sur les enjeux
écologiques euh mais qu'il a pas euh en
miroir si vous voulez son équivalent
politique en fait.
toutes les négociations internationales
sur le climat qui qui
n'ont dont les règles du jeu sont pipées
en fait euh
sont dans une logique euh
cosmétique
non sont dans une logique de de comment
dire étatique en fait d'égoïsmes
nationaux
le train de vie des
exactement le même débat qu'à l'échelle
qu'à l'échelle de l'Union européenne si
vous voulez est-ce que c'est le conseil
euh vous avez des négociations entre les
intérêts nationaux des uns et des autres
ou est-ce que c'est le parlement et donc
avec une logique transnationale et des
débats politiques à entre différentes
forces politiques à l'échelle à
l'échelle européenne ? C'est exactement
le même le même problème.
Donc on fait quoi ? On reste comme ça,
on fait des manifestations ensemble,
tout se passe bien, on fait la grève, on
reste comme ça.
Non, on prend le pouvoir.
On prend le pouvoir comment ? Comment
789 par les élections.
Par les élections. Et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui, il faut construire une
écologie de gouvernement, c'est-à-dire
capable d'exercer les responsabilités et
de préparer un programme de gouvernement
sérieux et crédible. pas seulement.
C'est crédible de dire ça.
Oui, c'est crédible de dire ça. Oui.
Après, si votre question c'est "Est-ce
queil y a énormément de travail à
accomplir pour être dans cette
situation,
il y a pas le choix."
Il y a pas le choix. Donc, est-ce qu'il
faut travailler vite ? La réponse est
oui. Euh est-ce que euh l'écologie
politique en France, elle a elle a euh
elle a ses mérites et cetera ? Quand je
dis ça, c'est pas du tout
comment dire une mais elle n'a elle n'a
pas fait ce travail là en tout cas
jusqu'à aujourd'hui. Elle ne l'a pas
fait, c'est-à-dire d'être crédible sur
les questions de défense, sur les
questions de politique économique, sur
toutes les questions régaliennes et
cetera. Ce travail-là n'a pas été fait.
Il doit être fait maintenant d'urgence
quand en face.
Pourquoi ? parce que l'écologie se
l'écologie politique se vivait
en mode pas cool, tout va bien.
Non, en mode force d'appoint en fait, en
mode le supplétif euh des uns ou des
autres dans le paysage qui manque. Hop,
on se on se verdit un peu, on prend 30 %
plus.
Mais là, c'est c'est plus du tout ça euh
la situation.
Donc, qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Il
faut dire à tous les écologistes de
sortir de tous les partis. Il faut faire
quoi ? Ça ça me paraît clair. Croire je
pense que cette page là est
définitivement tournée. C'est croire que
les formations politiques préexistante
allaient faire leur mutation. En tout
cas moi c'est le bilan j'en ai
la République en marche c'est nouveau.
Non je les range aussi dans le camp des
conservateurs et ils ont reproduit un
parti comme les anciens partis en fait
strict avec d'ailleurs les mêmes
procédures d'exclusion et cetera.
croire si vous voulez que ces formations
politiques vont faire leur mutation,
leur révolution écologique et cetera.
Tout ça est terminé. Donc la vision si
vous voulez d'une écologie consensuelle
dont tous les partis vont s'emparer qui
fait l'objet d'une espèce de voyez
domaine à part du débat politique dans
lequel tout le monde voterait pour le
bien commun. Tout ça c'est du baratin.
Donc il y a en fait le conflit majeur
aujourd'hui entre le système en place
que ce que j'appelle les destructeurs et
et l'intérêt des terriens. Euh il il se
fait sur le sur l'écologie qui donc
redéfinit l'éclivage politique. Et donc
oui, il faut que ceux qui sont euh
sincèrement euh mobilisés en fait euh
conscient des enjeux sur cette cause
rejoignent euh le le camp de l'écologie
politique dans sa diversité. Euh c'est
pas c'est pas un camp qui est qui est
qui est monolitique. Euh mais oui, il
faut faire ce choix-là aujourd'hui.
C'est le choix le plus utile.
Quand en face de vous euh certains
qualifient les écolos de de kmer vert de
de
de radicaux de de tout ça. H
qu'est-ce qu'il faut leur répondre ?
Qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez ?
Qu'est-ce que ça vous fait penser ? Quoi
? Ils se sentent menacés ? sont obligés
de vous militariser pour pouvoir vous
Je pense que les les comment dire euh
les rumeurs, le fait de de d'agiter des
peurs, ça agit comme peur,
non, ça a toujours existé.
Ça a toujours existé. Attendez, je vais
je vais y venir. Ça a toujours existé
face à à ceux qui veulent qui veulent
changer le monde. Euh les destructeurs,
euh leur
euh
Pourquoi vous les appelz les
destructeurs ?
parce que c'est euh aujourd'hui euh les
Trump, les Bolsonaro et cetera, le
gouvernement australien euh
sont ceux qui sont parfaitement informés
en fait euh de la situation dans
laquelle on est, parfaitement conscient
des limites planétaires et il prépare en
fait
la l'accélération de la captation d'un
maximum de ressources.
euh une logique en fait d'accumulation
de force de guerre euh et puissance
parce que
quand le gâteau sera dressit,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur la la
l'accession au ressources ?
On est dans une période d'accumulation
de force de guerre pour les ressources.
la une logique enfin une situation,
c'est la première fois que j'entends
quelqu'un en parler d'ailleurs,
une situation de pénurie
euh où déjà par exemple aujourd'hui on a
un certain nombre de de conflits de
guerres intraétatiques qui pour 40 %
d'entre elles
sont liées à des sécheresses, à des
famines et donc ont un lien direct avec
le changement climatique. Le fait que
des territoires entiers deviennent
inhabitables sur terre induisant des
mouvements de population.
Tout ça est porteur d'une logique
qui qui est une logique de
déstabilisation dans lequel
même les démocraties les plus solides
peuvent être balayées sous la sous la
pression des événements.
On est vraiment en fait aujourd'hui dans
un choix entre la barbarie ou
l'écologie. Et donc je les appelle les
destructeurs euh parce qu'ils sont euh
les promoteurs de l'amplification, de
l'accélération, de la poursuite de de ce
modèle en fait. Euh et qu'il il raconte
alors en plus on voit bien si vous
voulez dans leur dans le la mécanique
politique des régimes soit euh de nature
nationaliste ou autoritaire et cetera,
le lien qu'il y a entre euh la logique
euh de nationalisme et le sexisme et le
climato-obscurantisme. Le
climato-obscurantisme en fait c'est la
clé de voûte de leur discours.
Donc c'est c'est pas surprenant qu'un
Trump il aille à Davos pour dire à Greta
Tenberg prophète de malheur, ils sont au
combat idéologique en fait contre
l'écologie. Et dans ce combat
idéologique contre l'écologie, je
reviens à votre histoire de Cmervert
prophète de malheur et cetera. pas fait
de malheur, mais vous l'ajoute.
Euh en fait, il y a euh la technique euh
vieille vieille comme le monde qui
consiste euh à euh
en fait si vous voulez, ils vont pas
aller devant les gens pour dire "Non,
vous comprenez, l'intérêt des compagnies
pétrolières est beaucoup trop important
et" et cetera. Donc c'est toujours
soi-disant,
c'est votre emploi,
c'est toujours soisant voilà au nom du
peuple, pour votre bien euh mesdames et
messieurs, pour les plus pauvres d'entre
vous que il faut pas faire d'écologie.
euh tout l'imaginaire de l'écologie
punitive, du fait que l'écologie serait
un truc en fait euh de bobo, éduqué et
cetera. Tout cet imaginaire là en fait,
il est véhiculé par les tenants du du
statut CO. Et donc c'est Oui, il faut se
préparer même en France hein. Euh moi je
je pense qu'il faut se préparer même en
France à euh
la
euh
l'arrivée de de courant climato
obscurantiste, de de trucs comme ça. Euh
ça me surprendrait pas du tout. J'ouvre
une parenthèse euh un commentaire de la
communauté. Qu'est-ce qu'elle a à dire
sur le fait qu'elle a validé le projet
de 19 bassins de rétention d'eau dans sa
circonscription sud des deux Sèvres ?
J'étais pas au courant.
Ben en fait que moi je regarde la
réalité en face
et il faut organiser aujourd'hui là
des bassins qui servent à faire remonter
de l'eau des nappes fréatiques pour les
création intensive des cultures
céréaliennes.
C'est pas ça.
Non. Alors, c'est plus compliqué que ça
beaucoup mais parce que c'est pas du
tout ça en fait. Euh en fait, on doit
aujourd'hui organiser notre adaptation
au changement climatique et regarder la
réalité en face.
Donc ça c'est le projet de la FNSE
locale, c'est ça ? Non, c'est aussi
celui de Doèf Nature environnement et de
la coordination de défense du maré de
vin. Donc c'est un petit peu plus
c'est pas la présentation caricaturale
qui qui est faite. En fait, si vous
voulez, on est c'est un exemple de
terrain qui est d'ailleurs assez assez
intéressant
par rapport à la question de savoir si
on est capable aujourd'hui en fait de
prendre des décisions par rapport à ce
qu'on sait du changement climatique qui
est en cours ou pas.
Dans les deux sévres, aujourd'hui,
l'agriculture consomme trop d'eau pour
irriguer et donc il faut réduire les
prélèvements. Est-ce que demain on peut
continuer à faire de l'agriculture sans
eau du tout ? La réponse est non. Euh on
a euh des semaines de sécheresse
consécutive, on va passer à des 9
semaines de canicules consécutive et on
a des pluies diluviennes d'automne où
par exemple à Nior cet automne, il est
tombé en 3 jours, ce qui tombe
habituellement en plus d'un mois en
fait. Donc euh il y a cette question de
de du stockage euh de l'eau pour
maintenir une activité agricole parce
que moi euh je veux aussi dire que le
combat pour le maintien de l'agriculture
et le combat de l'écologie ne forme
qu'un seul.
Le film Au nom de la Terre pour ceux qui
l'ont vu, c'est une histoire vraie qui
se passe juste à côté de ma
circonscription.
des suicides d'agriculteurs, il y en a
tous les jours du fait du modèle actuel.
Donc on doit
pas seulement être dans la dénonciation
par rapport aux agriculteurs qui sont en
train de prendre conscience qu'il faut
changer de modèle. Est-ce que on leur
tend la main ou est-ce qu'on dit non, on
peut rien changer, il faut rien faire et
cetera. Moi, je fais le choix de tendre
la main et je fais le choix de vouloir
changer les choses dans la réalité. Donc
ce dont il s'agit dans ce projet, non
pas de 19 mais de 16 retenus de
substitution, c'est de diminuer
complètement enfin de façon très
importante en fait les prélèvements par
rapport à la situation d'aujourd'hui,
de prélever l'eau uniquement dans des
périodes de cru, donc quand il y en a
vraiment beaucoup et plus que ce que les
besoins que ce sont les besoins des
milieux naturels
et de conditionner parce que c'est très
important de conditionner l'accès à
l'irrigation, au changement des
pratiques agricoles et à la
reconstruction de la biodiversité.
Pas d'agroécologie,
pas d'accès à l'eau et à l'irrigation.
Donc c'est ça en fait ce projet qui est
contesté, ce qui est la liberté de de
mais ce qui
euh euh
est soutenu euh par, je vous disais la
coordination de défense du maré Poidvin
ou de SF nature environnement, une
association locale qui s'appelle le curé
ou la Fédération de pêche donc des
défenseurs de l'environnement.
Alors ce sujet-là d'ailleurs ce
commentaire de la communauté est très
intéressant. Vous avez regardé ce qui se
passait en Australie par rapport au
droits d'accès à l'eau ? Non,
cette financiarisation de l'accès à
l'eau, pas du tout.
Non, j'ai pas regardé mais c'est je je
doute pas du fait que ce soit très
intéressant en fait. Là, en l'occurrence
c'est un point qui est absolument
capital
en fait. Les droits d'accès à l'eau dans
le territoire dont il est question. Là,
c'est le bassin de la Sèvre Newortaise
qui alimente le marais poid de vin. Euh
c'est un organisme de l'État qui euh
délivre
euh les autorisations de prélèvement. Et
cet organisme de l'État donc qui est un
établissement public, dans sa
gouvernance,
vous avez le monde agricole, mais vous
avez aussi le monde associatif et les
élus locaux. Et c'est un cas très
particulier en France qui n'existe pas
dans d'autres territoires où vous n'avez
pas d'organisme d'État qui gère les
prélèvement et l'irrigation et vous
n'avez encore moins une gouvernance
associant
euh par exemple les associations de
protection de la nature.
Donc vous avez été ministre aussi de
l'énergie.
Oui.
Comment ça se passe quand on arrive et
qu'on est bombardé ministre de l'énergie
? On a on a rendez-vous avec qui ? Qui
est-ce qui vous informe ? Parce que par
exemple les services de renseignement
vous donnent des fiches pour vous
expliquer la géopolitique de l'énergie.
Est-ce que vous avez une formation
accéléré par les services de l'État pour
vous expliquer dans quoi vous embarquez
ou est-ce que vous avez déjà vos propres
connaissances quand vous arrivez ?
Alors, votre première question, je n'y
répondrai pas.
Pourquoi ? parce que euh j'ai été euh
j'ai été en fait vraiment choquée euh
quand l'ancien président de la
République François Hollande a révélé
l'existence de d'opération d'assassinats
ciblés euh sur des membres de l'État
islamique, c'est-à-dire quand celui qui
est le
pas de juge,
quand celui qui est le gardien euh du
secret défense euh s'assoit dessus. ce
qu'un président peut le ministère le
ministère de l'énergie
euh c'est le ministère dont le plus de
documents relèvent du confidentiel
défense. Moi j'ai dit énormément de
choses sur sur l'exercice du pouvoir,
sur l'influence des lobby avec bon toute
une série de de comment dire de faits
extrêmement précis. Mais il y a une
chose que je ne ferai jamais, c'est de
révéler des secrets d'état.
Euh je votre insu.
Je ne je même même je j'espère.
Vous comprenez ma question ?
Oui, je la comprends. Euh
j'espère.
Euh je ne en fait je ne le ferai pas.
Pourquoi ? Parce que je considère que
je ne peux pas exposer des
vulnérabilités.
C'est je ne peux pas parce que je vais
répondre sur telle ou telle question,
je sais pas moi, sur la sûreté des
centrales nucléaire,
sur les approvisionnements de la France
en celci ou cela ou sur les stocks
stratégiques. Exposer.
Il y a d'autres personnes qui le font à
votre place d'ailleurs.
Oui, bah très bien. Mais ils ont pas été
ministres et ils sont pas élus du
peuple. Voilà. Moi, je suis député de la
République française. J'ai été ministre
euh du gouvernement et je considère que
s'il y a un secret défense, c'est pas
pour rien.
D'accord. Alors, on va on va mettre un
peu de du light dans la question. Ouais.
Quand vous avez pris vos fonctions,
est-ce que vous avez eu une réunion avec
les services de renseignement ou avec
des services spéciaux pour vous
expliquer ? Voilà, faut faire attention
à ça. Vous vous allez être exposé à de
la surveillance de masse. D'ailleurs, la
rue d'en face est en train de nous
écouter. Donc les contrats, il faut pas
les mettre dans votre
si vous voulez bien, je vais prendre un
autre exemple euh qui un exemple plus
d'actualité et qui n'a rien à voir, mais
vous verrez le lien. Euh situation de
crise à Lubrisol, site CVSO.
Site CVO. Euh est-ce que les ministres
euh sont briefés ou ont fait des
exercices
de gestion de crise ? Juste de gestion
de crise ? La réponse est non. La
réponse est non
du tout.
Non.
C'est qu'ils ont jamais appris. Par
exemple, on va prendre un exemple qui
est un peu plus d'actualité. Le
coronavirus,
le brisol, c'est
le coronavirus. Il y a quand même des
exercices sur les caso. Pas du tout.
Non, sur les casseau il y en a pas.
C'est extraordinaire. C'est que la
gestion de rouant, l'évacuation de tout
ça. Non, mais il y a quand même des
exercices pour les centrales nucléaire.
Non, je parle sur sur l'expression du
ministre et sur sa sur sa propre
communication alors que il y a déjà eu
des problèmes à Lubriol, qu'il y a eu un
rapport d'inspection sur les précédents
problèmes à lu Brisole, que la
conclusion de ce rapport d'inspection,
c'est des choses très précises en
matière de communication, de
communication sur les réseaux sociaux,
d'expression de l'État et cetera et
cetera.
Ça n'a eu aucune aucune conséquence.
C'est c'est ça que je je relate. Ça n'
aucune conséquence. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'en fait, et ça répond en creux
peut-être à votre question,
en grand creux, hein.
L'écologie
n'est pas considérée comme une question
de sécurité nationale.
D'accord. L'énergie
non plus.
Non plus euh
pas comme ça devrait. Ça devrait être
comment à votre avis ?
Ça devrait être un ministère régalien.
C'est combien le budget du ministère de
l'écologie ?
Mais c'est alors là la colle, ils vont
trouver les les internautes.
C'est pas qu'une question de budget.
C'est une question de budget, ça c'est
extrêmement important. C'est une
question de loi de programmation et
cetera, mais pas seulement. C'est une
question, j'allais dire politique ou
psychologique si vous voulez de
comprendre qu'il y a des enjeux de
sécurité de la population, de sécurité
de la nation derrière non seulement les
questions énergétiques, mais plus
largement l'ensemble des enjeux
écologiques dans le monde d'aujourd'hui.
Je je termine juste avec un tout petit
bout de question sur ça parce que je
sens qu'il y a une petite adhérence
quand même. Quand vous avez pris vos
fonctions,
oui,
on vous a briefé un petit peu sur euh la
surveillance de vos ordinateurs, de
votre téléphone portable, ce qu'il faut
faire, pas faire ou pas du tout ?
Oui.
Qui qui combien de temps ?
Non, je je je
dirai pas davantage.
Bon, c'est déjà pas mal.
On va passer à des questions de la
communauté.
Comment va-t-elle se faire élire ?
question de Orange,
c'est à moi. Mais le problème c'est pas
comment moi je je me fais d'abord moi je
suis élu
euh
vous comptez vous présenter comme
présidente de la République ?
Alors euh pour répondre à cette question
très clairement euh le temps où les
écologistes font l'impasse euh sur
l'élection présidentielle
euh faut que ça ça suffit en fait. Euh
c'est pas possible. C'est comme si si je
prends la la métaphore footballistique,
c'est comme si vous jouez les matchs de
de qualification et pas la Coupe du
monde. On peut le regretter mais on est
malheureusement dans le système de la 5e
République avec une élection qui domine
et qui entraîne toutes les autres et en
particulier les élections législatives
qui est l'élection présidentielle.
La question qui nous est posée
aujourd'hui est pas de tomber pour ce
qui concerne les écologistes. On n'est
pas si vous voulez comme les autres. on
aurait un trop plein de déjà prétendant
à la candidature
et en fait aussi longtemps qu'on peut
protéger l'écologie
de de cette logique du présidentialisme,
en tout cas moi ce sera ce sera mon
ce sera mon crédau. Ce que je ferai
moi-même, c'est pas le problème en fait.
Mon problème aujourd'hui, c'est de
construire le mouvement collectif qui
permet d'y arriver et qui permettra à le
moment où faudra choisir un candidat de
faire le choix le plus intelligent.
Il y a il y a quelqu'un du Crédit
Suisse, un un haut dirigeant du Crédit
Suisse qui dit "Sans croissance, il n'y
a pas d'avenir possible."
Ah ben en fait, avec la croissance, il
n'y a pas euh d'avenir. C'est c'est ça
la situation.
Alors, autre question, c'est quoi la
C'est quoi le progrès ?
C'est le progrès de l'intelligence.
Euh c'est la croissance de notre
imaginaire,
euh de la culture,
des relations humaines,
de la science.
Euh donc c'est plus c'est plus la même
vision du progrès en fait. Cette idée de
progrès, elle est elle était très elle
était totalement productiviste en fait
dans son dans son approche et son
appréhension.
Bon, on va parler de nucléaire.
H
le nucléaire, pas de nucléaire. C'est
bien le nucléaire, c'est pas bien le
nucléaire. Est-ce qu'on utilise le
nucléaire pour absorber le choc
énergétique d'un pic énergétique
pétrolier ? Est-ce que le nucléaire, il
faut le bannir ? Est-ce qu'il faut
l'utiliser ? Il faut pas l'utiliser ?
Est-ce que vous comprenez ma question ?
Il y a beaucoup de tensions, beaucoup de
de de tension autour du nucléaire.
Ouais.
Est-ce que le nucléaire c'est bien pour
la France ?
Alors, d'abord cette tension autour le
autour du nucléaire, elle est
paralysante.
C'estàd qu'en fait aujourd'hui, par
exemple en France, il y a pas de vraie
politique d'économie d'énergie, ce qui
devrait être la priorité absolue à cause
des
sous-entendus des implications pour le
nucléaire. par exemple EDF, si vous
voulez combat
euh toute politique puissante d'économie
d'énergie, de réduction de la
consommation d'électricité parce que ils
ont peur que si on réduit la
consommation d'électricité, à ce
moment-là, ça change les termes du débat
sur le sur le il y a il y a un truc
complètement paralysant en fait dans à
cause de cette
polarisation.
du débat sur la politique énergétique
sur le nucléaire au point que vous avez
une majorité de Français qui sont pas au
courant que la principale énergie
consommée en France c'est du pétrole,
pas du nucléaire.
Charbon aussi, non ?
Voilà, charbon moins mais quand même.
Donc faut mettre les choses à leur
place. La priorité absolue, c'est de
réduire la consommation énergétique et
puis d'arrêter de l'amplifier.
Donc la 5G, le déploiement des écrans
numériques de publicité dans les villes,
faut arrêter le délire. Voilà, faut
réduire drastiquement la consommation
d'énergie en France. C'est la première
chose à faire.
Chauffé à combien chez vous ?
Alors moi je chauffe à 18
et je suis bien. Et au bureau, je
chauffe un peu plus chaud parce que au
bureau, je me je bouge pas en fait. Euh
et donc en fait comme chacun sait, ce
serait beaucoup mieux de travailler
debout et de faire un peu plus de
mouvement pour être moins dépendant du
chauffage. Euh donc bon voilà. Euh ça
c'est la première chose. La deuxième, on
a un parc nucléaire existant
euh qu'il faut réduire.
réduire, c'est-à-dire décommissionner,
déconstruire,
le moderniser qu'il faut réduire
progressivement. Tous ceux qui
viendraient en disant on peut sortir du
nucléaire demain matin racontent
n'importe quoi. Bon maintenant dépendre
à 75 %
d'une seule source de production avec
des centrales nucléaires qui sont par
ailleurs des modèles génériques et donc
quand il y a un pépin sur une euh il y a
le pépin sur plusieurs. Euh c'est pas
vous voyez en terme de résilience euh
c'est c'est pas très responsable.
Après, il y a le problème du coût,
c'est-à-dire de de du coût de de
production euh de de l'énergie nucléaire
qui qui n'est plus ce qu'il a été dans
le passé
et auquel s'ajoute quand même un
problème
qui est celui du statut de DF.
et de la nouvelle étape qui s'annonce
de privatisation,
bah en tout cas de scinder l'entreprise
en deux pour effectivement certainement
ce qui est tout pourri, on laisse à
l'état.
Voilà, on socialise les pertes, on
privatise les bénéfices. Euh
ça c'est qui gagne ça ? C'est pas
extraordinaire ça ? Mais ça c'est le
résultat en fait de ce qu'est la non
politique européenne aujourd'hui de
l'énergie qui est une politique de
dérégulation
qui ne considère pas l'énergie comme un
bien particulier par rapport à toutes
les règles
concurrence libre et non faussé et
cetera. C'estàd c'est pas considéré
comme un un bien fondamental qui
nécessite
des règles d'intervention publique et
des règles de gouvernance et de gestion
collective. différente des autres
secteurs d'activité économique.
Et c'est une catastrophe.
C'est une catastrophe. Ces règles là,
avec ces règles là, je dis pas que
c'était
avec ces règles là, jamais la France
n'aurait fait son parc nucléaire. Enfin,
on aura on serait pas du tout
jamais il y aura eu le service public de
l'électricité.
Pourquoi on a fait le parc nucléaire en
France ?
France ? Ce que je veux dire, c'est que
c'est l'État qui l'a payé. C'est pas le
marché qui l'a payé. Le le voilà. Donc
quand aujourd'hui on vient dire faut
investir dans les économies d'énergie,
faut investir dans les énergies
renouvelables et cetera et que le marché
dit non. Je rappelle que dans le passé,
je dis pas que c'était ça ou pas ça,
c'est le débat est pas de savoir s'il
faut refaire l'histoire. Le débat c'est
que c'est l'intervention publique qui à
un moment donné a dit voilà on décide de
faire ça voilà et qu'aujourd'hui où on
doit changer de modèle énergétique quand
on vient dire et ben il faut investir
là-dedans et que le marché ne le fait
pas et qu'on ne met pas en place les
régulations pour que le marché soit
obligé de le faire on a des règles du
jeu qui sont complètement absurdes en
fait voilà et qui entraînent même
aujourd'hui une logique de à terme de
démantellement de ce qui était EDF. Donc
ça c'est la deuxième chose. La
troisième, c'est qu'on est en train
d'assister
à la politique du fait accompli qui est
que le gouvernement actuel est en train
de décider la construction d'un nouveau
programme nucléaire
sans vrai débat démocratique,
sans qu'on ait le début d'un
commencement
d'information tant industrielle
qu'économique au regard de ce qu'est la
pantalonade.
de l'EPR de Flamville.
C'est quand même normal que la
représentation nationale dise que on
peut pas se lancer dans une fuite en
avant de ce genre.
Voilà. Et ce qui est très moi ce qui m'a
vraiment frappé si vous voulez sur le
sur le nucléaire la logique
d'aveuglement en fait. C'estàd qu'à un
moment donné, on est plus dans l'examen
rationnel euh d'un moyen de production
euh de ses avantages, de ses
inconvénients, des problèmes qui posent
en terme de sécurité et de sûreté de son
coût économique et puis on le compare
aux autres moyens de production et puis
on prend une décision pragmatique
rationnelle. On est dans une logique de
fuite en avant pour maintenir la filière
industrielle. Donc en fait, les
décisions de politique publique comme
par exemple celle de euh éventuellement
construire six nouveaux réacteurs en
France sont liés euh au maintien de la
filière Mox.
Alors le MOX, c'est un un amalgame entre
uranium et et
et euh
plutonium. C'est bien.
Ouais. Voilà. Et attends, on a pas
entendu.
Plutonium.
D'accord.
Ça change quand même les choses. Non, le
Mox non Mox Fukushima, c'était bien.
En tout cas,
la différence entre l'uranium et le
plutonium.
Non, je je joue pas à ça en fait.
La demi-vie du plutonium, c'est
Non, je je suis pas venu pour ça. Euh et
je suis pas un singe savon.
C'est pas une histoire d'être singe
savant. C'est une histoire de comprendre
que quand on met du plutonium dans des
crayons de combustible, c'est pas la
même chose quand quand ça c'est des
cartons.
D'accord. Mais
je je c'est c'est pas ma logique ça en
fait.
Autant vous voyez vous vous posiez la
question de comment ça se passe dans le
dans les dans les fonctions
gouvernementales.
Vous passez votre temps à être confronté
à des gens qui vous disent c'est pas
possible hein. Donc avant tout arbitrage
et toute décision vous êtes obligé de de
bosser techniquement euh si vous voulez
à fond. Mais j'ai pas une mémoire qui
soit une mémoire d'ordinateur euh de
bosser à fond pour contester tel
techniquement tel ou tel argument. Mais
je mais je suis pas là, je suis pas venu
pour euh faire une interro écrite sur
mes anciennes connaissances sur la
chimie. Pardon. C'est combien le ticket
du prix ? Le ticket de métro, il est à
combien ?
J'ai un pass navigo. Donc voilà. Euh je
ne maîtrise pas le l'état actuel du
ticket de métro qui doit être un 20 ou
un 40 ou je ne sais quoi. Euh
donc on en était où en fait ?
La préservation de la filière nucléaire.
Oui. Enfin je décrivais l'aveuglement.
l'aveuglement qui qui est le qui est
celui d'un système qui qui n'a pour seul
but en fait
pas la politique énergétique de la
France qui n'a pour seul but que son
autoreonduction et c'est un problème.
C'est un problème parce que ça donne
lieu à un aveuglement.
Euh
alors le le l'exemple spectaculaire,
c'est Flamville, hein. Et alors quand on
va chercher
le rapport fault
qu'on retrouve
dans l'histoire al stom général
électrique
pour nous dire que
en fait on va pouvoir remédier
au problème de la filière nucléaire
parce que maintenant on a une vision
claire de ce qui n'a pas fonctionné dans
dans le PR de Flammenville. Euh
le le le mêmes constats étaient fait si
vous voulez il y a euh 2 ans, il y a 3
ans, il y a 4 ans et cetera. C'estàd que
le récit de euh les chiffres étaient
sous-évalués, les compétences
industrielles ont été perdues et cetera,
c'est l'histoire qui qui est racontée
maintenant depuis des années et pour
l'instant il fonctionne toujours pas.
Comment on fait pour changer tout ça
Donc voilà, moi je je il faut dissocier
ce qui est la question
du parc actuel et de sa diminution
progressive
de ce délire qui serait le fait de
partir dans la relance d'un programme
nucléaire en France.
Vous vous qualifiez ça d'un délire. Mais
si on en avait besoin d'ailleurs,
si la rareté de l'accès à l'énergie, si
les tensions géopolitiques
ne nécessitait pas qu'on refasse comme
il y a 50 ans, c'est-à-dire que on est
notre approvisionnement énergétique.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que la chose
principale à faire,
on ne l'a fait pas ? Moi, je veux bien
avoir en fait tous les
choses principale
les économies d'énergie.
Les économies d'énergie.
Après, je dire on pourra discuter tout
sur ce qu'il faudra faire dans 30 ans,
dans 40 ans, dans 50 ans et cetera. En
attendant, il y a un constat unanime de
tous les experts du sujet, ceux qui sont
contre le nucléaire, ceux qui sont pour
le nucléaire et cetera. Tout le monde
dit il y a une chose à faire là tout de
suite maintenant, c'est réduire la
consommation d'énergie et on le fait
pas. Et alors par contre, on est les
champions du monde de savoir si en 2070
on aura encore de ceci, si on aura
trouvé du stockage euh par l'hydrogène
ou pas et le biogaz et cetera. Mais en
fait, faisons ce qu'il faut faire là
tout. Pourquoi on fait pas ? Pourquoi on
le fait pas ?
Pour les résults,
on plante l'économie.
C'est pas vrai. Alors, c'est en plus ça
qui est paradoxal, c'est qu'à court
terme à court terme euh les économies
d'énergie ont plutôt des effets de
relance en fait euh notamment par
l'activité sur les travaux de sur les
travaux d'économie d'énergie et et les
travaux d'efficacité énergétique. que à
court terme ça n'a ça n'a pas cette cet
effet induit là d'investir dans les
économies d'énergie massives.
La voiture électrique c'est bien, c'est
pas bien.
En fait dans voiture électrique le
problème c'est c'est le mot c'est le mot
voiture en fait.
C'est-à-dire que dans le dans les débats
sur la mobilité euh les débats sont
enfermés depuis des années dans un débat
de technologie en fait. Alors, est-ce
que c'est euh l'électrique, l'hydrogène,
le biogaz ? Euh euh de la même façon que
le débat sur les transport, il a été
enfermé dans un débat sur le report
modal en fait, sans se poser jamais.
Report modal, il faut expliquer pour
ceux qui
c'est-à-dire il faut euh au lieu qu'il y
ait des camions, il faut qu'il y ait des
trains, au lieu qu'il y ait des
voitures, il faut qu'il y ait des RER
sans jamais se poser la question
de en fait l'augmentation de la
distance.
C'est l'augmentation du temps de
transport dans nos vies qui fait des
vies pourries. C'est 1h30 le matin, 1h30
le soir, rentrer à 20h, pas avoir fait
le dîner aux enfants, pas avoir pu leur
donner le bain, être épuisé parce qu'on
a passé du temps soit dans des RER où on
est serré comme ça, soit parce qu'on
était dans les embouteillages assez
énervés. C'est pas une bonne qualité de
vie en fait. Et donc la vraie politique
structurante qu'il faut avoir
aujourd'hui, c'est une politique de
démobilité.
C'est c'est j'ai fait un un rapport
parlementaire sur l'industrie
automobile. J'étais très frappée que
tous les industriels de l'automobile,
ils basaient leurs prévisions sur
l'augmentation des besoins de mobilité.
Et en fait, c'est l'augmentation de la
croissance. C'est la même chose parce
que la mobilité derrière ce qui a
structuré les territoires, c'est les
énergies fossiles. Et le mouvement des
gilets jaunes, c'est ça en fait, c'est
le ralbol de la France des ronds-points.
C'est le le le ralbol de la France où on
supprime les services publics, où faut
prendre sa bagnole pour tout et rien et
où les distances s'allongent. En fait,
c'est l'envie d' de retrouver euh une
proximité dans ce que ce que j'évoquéis
tout à l'heure sur ce 9 français sur 10
qui veulent ralentir, c'est cette
questionlà en fait, c'est celle de
réduire le trend de transport. Après, on
peut débattre de la façon dont on
accomplit ce temps de transport,
covoiturage, métro, tramouf, vélo,
marche à pied et cetera. Mais là aussi,
il faut remettre les choses dans le dans
le bon ordre. Ce qu'il faut organiser
aujourd'hui, c'est la démobilité. C'est
le fait d'arrêter d'allonger les
distances. Donc bah, par exemple, les
nouveaux centres commerciaux,
stop.
Avec des caisses automatiques,
voilà, avec des caisses automatiques.
Stop. Stop. Et après, on pleure sur le
la fermeture des commerces de
Centrre-ville.
Les nouveaux lottissements alors qu'on a
des maisons euh anciennes dans les cœurs
de bourg qui sont à Stop. Stop. Voilà.
Donc la première question, c'est pas
celle du type de véhicule en fait, c'est
de réduire le besoin de voiture et de
réduire le besoin de transport. Ensuite,
on peut discuter effectivement sur le
point de vue des technologies en tant
que tel
de laquelle est la plus pertinente par
rapport à laquelle usage parce que
la voiture électrique, c'est pertinent
en terme de pollution, en terme
d'écologie, en terme de
C'est pertinent en fait. Alors moi, dans
mon souvenir, c'est la dernière étude
que j'avais lu là-dessus au moment où
j'avais fait mon rapport parlementaire,
mais je sais que depuis il y en a eu de
nouvelles. La avait évalué que ça
n'avait de ça n'avait si vous voulez une
plus-value écologique qu'à partir du
moment où le véhicule électrique euh
dépassait les 50000 km et où il était
très utilisé. Euh c'est-à-dire que
d'avoir une voiture électrique pour la
laisser dans son parking et de s'en
servir que de temps en temps alors que
la voiture principale, ce serait une
voiture à énergie fossile. C'est
l'inverse de ce qu'il faut faire en
fait. C'estd que sinon si vous êtes dans
ce type d'usage là euh ou de plus
exactement de non usage du véhicule
électrique, bah ça fait une dépense
ressource globale pour créer cette
voiture électrique et qui est pas du
tout amortie.
Si vous si vous en servez pas beaucoup
en fait concrètement.
Alors, une question qui n'a rien à voir
peut-être un peu les ventes d'armes à
l'Arabie Saoudite, question de
arpenteur.
H
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce
que c'est bien ? C'est pas bien ? Est-ce
que c'est normal ? C'est du business
comme un autre ?
Non, c'est pas du business comme un
autre.
C'est pas du business comme un autre. Et
non, ça me paraît pas normal
de la même façon
que ne me paraît pas normal euh qu'une
centrale à gaz euh de total
euh financé indirectement par la France
au travers des aides à l'export,
euh
bah on apprenne que elle est utilisée
comme une espèce de comme une espèce de
prison manifestement.
Et en fait cette
cette histoire des aides à l'export aux
énergies fossiles me paraît vraiment
très importante en fait euh parce que la
France au cours des 10 dernières années
a
assuré pour 9 milliards d'euros
de capitaux investis dans la
construction de nouvelles centrales à
énergie fossile de par le monde.
dans un contexte où l'Agence
internationale à l'énergie dit euh zéro
fossil supplémentaire, zéro. Pas bah le
gaz, c'est moins grave que le charbon et
cetera. 0 CO2 en plus par rapport aux
capacités existantes
et la France à travers ses garanties de
l'État, donc c'est pas une subvention,
c'est le fait d'assurer le risque. Elle
assure des projets qui se font dans des
zones en général peu stables.
C'est la COFAS qui fait ça ? Non, c'est
pas la COF
maintenant c'est BPI France. Mais en
fait, c'est pas BPI France, c'est c'est
l'État. C'est le ministre de l'économie
qui décide
et qui signe. La BPI France instruit
comme la COFAS avant instruisait. C'est
des aides à l'export qui relèvent des
prérogatives directes du gouvernement et
du ministre de l'économie et des
finances.
En fait, on est sur des des
installations, vous avez pas une banque
en fait qui portera le risque. C'est les
Français qui portent le risque de la
construction. euh par exemple là euh au
Mozambique euh d'une installation euh
gazière extrêmement importante euh par
total avec plus de donc 900 millions
d'euros euh 500 millions d'euros pardon
de garantie de l'État à Technip parce
qu'en plus euh dans
Technip qui nous appartenait. C'est ça.
C'est ça. C'est-à-dire quand on regarde
les bénéficiaires des garanties de
l'État,
on retrouve général électrique pour plus
de 250 millions d'euros en 2017.
On retrouve Technipp.
Alors Technipp, ça nous appartenait.
C'est ça,
c'est ça, c'est ça. Ben non,
jusqu'à ce qu'il y a une enquête
euh du
OJ et que ce soit fusionné, racheté par
les Américains. J'ai vu qu'il y avait un
dernier épisode où c'est scindé
finalement deux entreprises
basé au Pays-Bas pour l'une.
Pourquoi on laisse faire tout ça ? On
n'est pas obligé de laisser faire tout
ça. On est absolument pas obligé.
Et c'est vous savez, j'avais réussi à
faire voter en commission des affaires
économiques la suppression, donc
l'interdiction des aides à l'export aux
énergies fossiles. Et en premier abord,
vous voyez dans le débat, tous les
collègues ont dit "Bah oui, c'est
évident quoi, on va pas continuer à à
mettre de la garantie publique
sur des centrales à énergie fossile,
quel qu'en soit la nature." Donc
l'amendement est voté avec le soutien du
rapporteur et cetera. Qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans les jours qu'on suivit
en fait avant la séance ? Euh le
rapporteur, il a eu et je le remercie
vraiment sincèrement, il a eu
l'honnêteté de le dire en séance.
Comment il s'appelait ? Oh
euh
j'ai peur dire une euh voilà, j'ai la
mémoire qui flanche. Qu'il me pardonne
euh qu'il me pardonne, ça me ça me
reviendra. Euh il il a dit en séance, il
a dit euh
"Oui, c'est très compliqué de décider
ça. Euh euh j'ai eu un certain nombre de
coups de fil euh notamment de général
électrique.
Voilà ce qui s'est passé et donc
l'amendement a été supprimé
au bénéfice d'un amendement qui donc
inscrit dans la loi l'interdiction de
garantir des projets de construction de
centrale à charbon, ce qui était déjà
décidé et déjà en vigueur depuis 2015,
donc ce qui n'apporte rien.
On va parler de lobbying. Hm.
Euh là euh le lobbing il est
transparent, il est pas transparent
auprès de nos élus
dans une histoire comme ça.
Oui,
il est pas du tout transparent. C'est
pour ça que je remercie le rapporteur de
l'avoir dit parce que d'habitude ils le
disent pas en fait. Ils le disent pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé dans les
coulisses. En fait, tous les débats là
actuels sur, je veux dire, les vrais
lobbyistes qui se présente si vous
voulez devant vous avec un badge
lobbyiste et cetera, c'est une blague
par rapport à par rapport à la réalité
de la façon dont les choses se passent.
Non, vous voyez le fait de par exemple,
ce qui est très bien de mettre quand
dans les amendements qui sont proposés
de d'écrire dans l'exposé des motifs de
l'amendement de de quel qui a suggéré
l'amendement euh bon
qui a fait la photocopie.
Voilà. Euh c'est c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout le le niveau auquel se
passent les choses. En fait,
je cherche quelque chose dans mes notes,
je suis infiniment désolé. Euh on va
voir ça plus tard.
C'était sur le lobbing. Bon, façon ça va
revenir. C'est l'assemblée a pas enterré
le projet de lobbing transparent là.
Mais en fait, je pense que le la
question de la transparence, moi en fait
maintenant je je suis pas d'accord quoi.
Pourquoi ?
Euh moi je crois que la vraie question
c'est celle de la République
incorruptible.
Donc la question en fait euh c'est celle
de
de la séparation euh de l'État et du
secteur privé.
Euh en 1905, on a fait la séparation de
l'église et de l'État. Aujourd'hui, il
faut faire la séparation de l'État et du
et du secteur privé.
Donc s'en tenir, si vous voulez
seulement à la logique euh de mettre de
la lumière euh sur les démarches
officielles des entreprises vis-à-vis
des décideurs publics, c'est la moindre
des choses. Mais l'influence ne se passe
pas comme ça. L'influence, elle se passe
dans le fait que
en général commence dans les cabinets
ministériels
des jeunes haut fonctionnaires brillants
qui aspirent et c'est un problème,
comment ça se fait que c'est ça leur
aspiration ? Qui aspirent grâce à leur
passage par le cabinet ministériel ? le
sas en fait pour devenir intéressant
pour être débauché par tel ou tel grand
groupe
qui embauche pas seulement une
compétence et une personne qui embauche
un carnet d'adresse, qui embauche le la
liste des copains de promo, qui embauche
la connaissance de du fonctionnement de
l'État
et ce système d'aller-retour en fait
entre
une formation délivrée par la puissance
publique
des fonctions en cabinet ministériel
pour être débauché ensuite
en entreprise dans des conditions où en
plus les règles de déontologie
ne sont pas respectées dans un certain
nombre de cas. puis ensuite revenir dans
le secteur public euh où là alors on
vient avec le le carnet d'adresse de bon
c'est plus possible et c'est par là que
ça passe en fait la vraie influence des
lobbies elle c'est par là qu'elle passe.
C'est pas c'est normal que les
entreprises en fait défendent leur point
leur point de vue dans des dans des
débats.
anormal que le parlement a tellement pas
de moyens et de moyens d'expertise
technique, scientifique, économique et
cetera que il soit dépendant de la note
qui va être faite par telle ou telle
entreprise pour calculer mais enfin
toute une série de choses. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait le problème du poids du
lobbying, c'est aussi le problème de la
question de l'expertise, que ce soit
celle de la démocratie et du parlement
ou que ce soit celle de l'État. Euh donc
cette question de l'expertise, elle est
centrale. Alors encore plus quand on
parle de santé publique et de pesticides
où je rappelle que toutes les décisions
publiques sont prises sur la base
d'études qui sont payées par les firmes
qui fabriquent les produits, ce qui est
quand même incroyable. Bon euh donc
cette question si vous voulez de réarmer
l'État en terme de capacité technique,
de capacité scientifique sont euh
absolument capitales. Mais faut mettre
fin à la confusion des rôles et autant
vous voyez je pense que
comment dire sur le plan théorique, je
suis vraiment profondément convaincue
que c'est super d'avoir dans l'état des
gens qui sont passés par le secteur
privé, qui ont une diversité
d'expérience et cetera. Je pense que le
niveau actuel de corruption culturelle
est tel qu'il faut interdire
euh tous ces systèmes d'aller-retour
dans le privé. Voilà, quand on fait le
choix
de s'engager pour l'État, on fait le
choix de l'éthique de l'État et donc
c'est pas parti pour partir dans le
secteur privé. Et le pire aujourd'hui,
c'est que les haut fonctionnaires qui
sont des vrais serviteurs de l'État, qui
font pas le choix de partir dans le
secteur privé malgré les ponts en or qui
leur sont proposés, ben ils sont vu
comme des hasbines,
ils sont vus comme des gens qui ont pas
compris.
Euh oui, mais je veux dire des des
personnes qui ont vraiment si vous
voulez le le voilà la passion de l'État,
le sens de l'intérêt général qui croi à
son rôle et qui font pas le choix de de
céder
aux sirènes de l'appel du secteur privé.
par leur père, ils sont pas vus comme
des héros en fait alors qu'il devraient
être vu comme des desotness en fait de
la puissance publique. Otness, c'est une
c'est un très bon exemple. Ça vient de
quoi ? Ça vient de notre système
éducatif qui élève des bébés requins
pour manger des petits requins. C'est
c'est
non, ça vient des années 80 de la
de quoi ? Freak fou la finance fol.
Ouais. La finance folle la la le la
fascination pour euh moi franchement
est-ce que c'est un mépris de classe ?
C'est-à-dire
c'est-à-dire que
le fils de bébé requin va faire son
étude dans requin université baigné dans
un monde de requin université avec des
bébés requins partout. Le but du jeu
c'est de manger tout le monde. Et
ensuite quand on se retrouve face à
quelqu'un qui se bat pour l'intérêt
général pour son prochain, il est
considéré comme un moins que rien et et
c'est une culture qui s'est organisée au
sein de laer classe. Est-ce que c'est
comme ça que ça se passe ? Ouais quand
même,
j'ai pas suffisamment regardé dans le
dans le détail parce que c'est pas c'est
pas le centre de mon euh mais qui ait
peut-être une
une
différence entre euh si je si
j'interprète ce que vous voulez dire,
c'est-à-dire des des haut fonctionnaires
qui le seraient devenus par eux-mêmes,
par leur la force de leur de leur
travail et non pas par leur origine
sociale euh certainement mais c'est pas
je veux dire il y a des il y a des
exceptions notoires que je connais euh
non il y a des exceptions notoires.
Voilà donc en fait cette cette espèce
d'ivresse euh elle
elle a contaminé beaucoup. Voilà
contaminé beaucoup et il faut
aujourd'hui en sortir.
On en sort, on les vaccine, on fait
comment ?
Ah moi je je pense qu'on on demande on
demande un choix.
Prison la prison.
Non, on demande un choix. C'est dehors
ou dedans. Mais pas les deux. Pas les
deux. Pas les deux.
Voyez, je je peux prendre un exemple qui
est
celui de
question d'internet. Faut-il rétablir le
crime de haute trahison pour ceux qui
bradent nos bijoux de famille ou privé
ou à l'étranger ? Je rajouterai.
Euh je pense que c'est c'est
je suis pas dans cette logique là moi
euh
de faire des procès pour autre trahison.
Par contre, je pense que si les
commissions d'enquête parlementaires en
France pouvaient convoquer euh les
présidents de la République et leur
entourage, euh ça serait indispensable.
Vous êtes plutôt Robespierre ou Mara ?
Ni l'un ni l'autre.
Pourquoi ?
Euh d'abord parce que je suis une femme.
Euh et donc il y en a Ralbol qu'on
demande au aux femmes de se de se
comparer à des à des euh
héros ou pas d'ailleurs homme.
Euh ensuite parce que si on penche vers
la vers la révolution française
euh
ça peut déraper. Non, c'est pas ça.
C'est que j'avais j'avais plus de
j'avais plus d'intérêt en tout cas quand
j'étais quand j'étais jeune et que
j'étais très fascinée par la Révolution
française. J'avais plus d'intérêt pour
par exemple pour Camille Desmoulin
peut-être à cause de sa jeunesse.
Euh
voilà.
Le CCE.
Ouais.
Bien. Pas bien.
Non, pas bien.
Pourquoi ?
parce qu'en fait il fallait euh c une
aideisée,
bah surtout c'est une aide payée par les
ménage.
C'est une aide payé par la fiscalité
écologique
que c'est une aide indifférencié
donc en fait qui perd
sa capacité en en terme de force de
frappe économique parce qu'en fait c'est
pas du tout la même chose si vous voulez
en terme d'aide aux entreprises. Je vais
je vais caricaturer à l'extrême si vous
donnez 1 € à tout le monde ou si vous
mettez des milliards sur tel ou tel
secteur industriel.
Et là, le choix qui a été fait, c'est en
fait de donner à tout le monde à ceux
qui avaient besoin comme à ceux qui
avaient pas besoin en fait. Et du coup
euh la puissance de frappe qui qu'il
fallait probablement mettre sur un
certain nombre de secteurs, euh ça ça a
pas le choix qui c'est pas le choix qui
qui a été fait.
Ça a été encadré, contrôlé l'argent qui
a été arrosé.
Non, globalement non.
Moi, j'étais à l'époque plutôt pour une
stratégie d'aide à l'investissement en
fait ciblé des entreprises. On me
répondait que les entreprises risquaient
d'acheter des machines outils allemandes
ou italiennes. Je répondais que c'était
l'Europe, donc c'était quand même moins
pire que de jeter de l'argent par les
fenêtres et puis que ça avait ça allait
avoir en fait depuis l'appareil de
production français, c'est quand même
c'est quand même modernisé. Euh mais à
l'époque en 2012 2013 euh
on avait quand même beaucoup d'usine qui
avait pas qui avaient pas investi, qui
avaient pas rénové leur leur méthode de
production depuis longtemps.
Question qui revient beaucoup, le CTA,
le TAFTA, tous ces grands accords,
euh bah c'est la gouvernance officielle
des lobbyes, c'est l'étape ultime en
quelque sorte.
Euh c'est-à-dire que c'est euh mettre en
place un système qui autorise une
multinationale
à attaquer une nation souveraine et
démocratique devant un tribunal
d'arbitrage pour avoir pris une mesure
protégeant, je sais pas moi,
l'environnement, la santé publique et
cetera. Euh c'est terrible. regarder le
Trump et sa déclaration là il y a
quelques quelques jours
exigeant que dans les négociations
commerciales puisqueen fait le TAFTA
c'est c'est ça redevient d'actualité euh
contrairement au fait qu'on nous avait
dit "Vous inquiétez pas, il y aura
jamais d'accords commerciaux avec des
pays qui ne sont pas dans l'accord de
Paris pour le climat et cetera. à peine
les européennes étaient finies que les
négociations reprenaient. Et donc il
exige et il dit que c'est une barrière
c'est une barrière réglementaire indu le
fait qu'on interdise le poulet au chlore
et le bof aux hormones.
Et les États-Unis exigent bon imaginez
voilà et le sur le CTA alors on est dans
une situation sur le CTA qui est quand
même
très particulière. Euh puisque'en fait
il y a eu un premier vote de
ratification en juillet
euh qui s'est mal passé pour la majorité
même s'ils l'ont gagné. C'est le vote le
plus serré en fait depuis le début du
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Assemblée nationale et normalement le
CTA devait revenir en 2e cet automne et
il revient pas et on sait pas quand il
va revenir et donc en fait il est pas
ratifié
mais il s'applique quand même c'est il
n'a pas été ratifié
par la France
mais il s'applique quand même de façon
provisoire
c'est magnifique. Oui, c'est magnifique.
Vous voulez rajouter quelques mots
là-dessus ?
Non, je pense c'est assez clair.
Euh
les retraites
h
le gouvernement il fait bien, il fait
pas bien, la retraite universelle, la
retraite à point, le régime universel,
c'est quoi ? C'est des éléments de
langage. On se prépare à diminuer le le
point de la retraite.
Bon, d'abord, il fait pas bien. Je pense
que même le Conseil d'État le dit
maintenant. Donc euh ensuite euh
moi j'inscris le la République
écologique
comme une nouvelle étape en fait de la
construction républicaine.
Il y a eu la Révolution française, il y
a eu l'école obligatoire, laïcité, il y
a eu le programme du Conseil national de
la Résistance avec tous les outils de
protection sociale et il y a maintenant
une nouvelle étape à accomplir qui est
celle de ce que j'appelle l'état
résilience.
Cette étape là, elle passe pas par la
destruction des précédentes en fait.
Donc on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
entraîner le pays
dans une dans une marche en avant
urgente
dont dépend la sécurité de la population
et cetera et cetera en remettant en
cause euh des choses fondamentales. Et
en fait, je pense que tout le monde,
enfin comment dire, personne n'a tabou
en fait en tant que tel sur une histoire
de système universel, d'autant qu'on
prend les mots de la République, système
universel,
gestion par point. La question que je me
suis posé moi, mais c'est pourquoi en
1945 ils les ont pas supprimés en fait
les régimes obligatoires ou les régimes
spéciaux et cetera ? En fait, ils les
ont pas supprimés
parce que il pouvait pas être question
d'un nivel par le bas.
Et comme en fait ces régimes étaient
antérieurs à 1945,
qu'ils avaient été créés pour attirer
les salariés dans des professions
fondamentales
pour la nation,
cheminaux, policiers, enfin des
professions dans lesquelles fallait
garder les gens. Et donc le en fait
l'existence du régime de retraite,
c'était une manière d'être attractif en
fait pour ces pour ces métiers. Il ils
ont pas touché à ça. Est-ce que
aujourd'hui ou demain, on peut euh y
toucher ? Pourquoi pas ? Mais pas en
enlevant des droits aux gens. Alors là,
c'est ça, c'est ça qui se passe. C'est
un truc voilà, sans parler du système de
qui va fixer la valeur du point, du fait
que toutes les inégalités, les
injustices actuelles, retraite des
femmes 42 % inférieur à retraite des
hommes. Euh euh au début, moi quand j'ai
entendu 1000 € minimum, je me suis dit
bah ça c'est bien. Je me suis dit ça
c'est bien. Puis en fait c'est pour une
carrière complète au SMIC. Donc en fait
par exemple concrètement la situation
des agriculteurs des deux Sèvres qui
pour un/ers d'entre eux sont en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté, sont même en
dessous de 350 € par mois, euh
ben en en fait, ils auront le minimum
vieillesse mais ils ont c'est c'est pas
un minimum vieillesse à 1000 € qu'ils
ont annoncé en fait, c'est pour une
carrière complète au SMIC. Voilà. Donc
toutes les
le système par point, il risque
d'aboutir au fait dans la logique de
tout compte qu'on a plus le le l'effet
de lissage en fait des 25 meilleures
années, que toutes les années de galère
et cetera comptent. Voilà. Donc moi, je
suis pas euh euh comment dire ? Je suis
pas
euh conservatrice.
J'arrive pas à comprendre l'urgence de
cette réforme du point de vue financier.
J'arrive pas à comprendre par ailleurs
les modèles économiques de calcul de
cette réforme basé sur un taux de
croissance qui ne connaîtra jamais
d'accoup, jamais de problème. Vous voyez
qu'il y a un truc linéaire
qui est crédible comme moi je suis pape
pap
papesse. Voilà.
Bon, on vous réinvitera pour les
retraites. On vous on fera un petit une
petite émission autour de ce sujet là.
Question Snowdon à Sange là, il nous
demande votre avis. Snowdon à Sange, on
leur donne l'asile, on leur donne pas
l'asile,
c'est des criminels, c'est pas des
criminels ? C'est quoi ?
Je pense pas que je les mettrai sur le
même plan.
Pourquoi donc ?
Peut-être parce que l'un paraît plus
sympathique que l'autre, mais bon, ça
c'est totalement qui est sympathique.
Snowden me paraît plus sympathique.
Euh
en tout cas euh moi j'ai été marquée par
le manque de réaction
européenne et française
euh quand on a appris que nos présidents
de la République étaient espionnés par
la NSA.
Il faut pas les froisser,
c'est pas grave. C'est nos alliés.
Ce sont nos alliés. Les Américains sont
nos alliés. Euh mais je pense pas qu'un
allié vous
respecte plus en fait euh si vous
baissez la tête quoi.
Et
et là c'est une attente très grave à la
souveraineté.
Euh
dans les faits,
c'est J'entends je vous coupe, je vous
coupe, je suis désolé,
j'entends beaucoup le mot souveraineté
revenir dans votre bouche.
C'est le nouvel argument de campagne de
tous les politiques là.
Moi, pour moi, c'est pas quelque chose
de nouveau et je vois pas j'entends pas
tout le monde en parler, mais peut-être
qui c'est qui n'en parle pas ?
H
la gauche n'en parle pas. Euh les
écologistes je pense n'en parlent pas
assez euh alors que c'est central. Euh
bon les libéraux évidemment n'en parle
pas je le mettais de côté. Euh
euh
moi ce que j'entends par euh
souveraineté, c'est la possibilité euh
pour le pour le peuple de gouverner euh
c'est-à-dire expulser des diplomates
américains en mesure de rétorsion aux
écoutes qu'ils ont pu faire sur nos
différents présidents.
Expuls ? Je pense pas.
Euh je sais qu'ils ont été convoqués
mais j'ai trouvé les déclarations
publiques extrêmement molles.
Molle mle genre un peu comme un petit
flambi ou
je je rentrerai pas dans ce type de
commentaire. euh
molle, arrangeante
euh
et euh euh
décidant délibérément, si vous voulez,
d'éteindre une crise diplomatique avant
même qu'elle ait lieu, hein. Euh et
parfois même avec un allié, euh il faut
se fâcher en fait.
Faut se faire acheter.
On s'est fait acheter derrière,
c'est-à-dire que on a on avait plus de
capacité dans le problème qui est
derrière.
Donc on a laissé faire
le problème qui est derrière, je pense
sur beaucoup de d'aspects qu'on a évoqué
euh
c'est notre
notre perte
de capacité autonome sur sur notre
propre sécurité. En fait,
c'est qu'on est devenu une puissance de
moyenne impuissance.
Moi, j'aime je je
suis vraiment pas voyez dans la je
considère pas que la France un pays qui
pèse plus rien euh
qu'on puisse rien faire
mais notre d'avoir nos propres capacités
géostratégiques
et militaires,
c'est une question fondamentale.
Ça commence par le renseignement. Oui.
Revenons à à Snowdon.
Ouais.
On lui accorde l'asile.
Oui.
Pourquoi le gouvernement le fait pas ?
Pour pas fâcher les Américains
certainement. Je sais pas. Je sais même
pas s'ils se sont posés la question.
Nous, on a posé la question à Cédrico.
Ah qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Il a fait un petit peu languille. H
il a pas dit grand-chose.
On va parler de Greta Tonberg.
Greta Tonberg, on lui accorde l'asile.
Elle a pas besoin.
Laurent Alexandre essaie de la
psychiatriser.
C'est normal, c'est pas normal.
Euh
c'est d'un niveau de
euh condensé
euh de
misogénie
euh
de en creux si vous voulez la
démonstration d'une
d'une espèce de vulnérabilité. qu'il
qu'il ressent par le fait qu'une jeune
adolescente,
une femme soit soit aussi aussi
déterminé,
tiennent un discours aussi
aussi fort. Euh voilà, on sent que ça
atteint chez lui quelque chose de de
fondamental quoi.
C'est euh c'est
le porte-parole aujourd'hui, je pense,
du euh du climat obscurantisme bon
teint. Laurent Alexandre en France,
est-ce que vous comprenez son point de
vue ?
À qui ? À Laurent Alexandre. Non.
Est-ce que vous avez essayé de
comprendre son point de vue ?
Je cherche pas à le comprendre. Je vois
bien tout l'univers idéologique en fait
qu'elle a. Quel est son
euh l'univers idéologique ? Euh c'est
euh on trouvera toujours une solution
technologique, on pourra aller sur Mars,
euh faut faire confiance euh
euh au progrès, euh rien ne s'effondre.
Euh
il faut relativiser toutes les
informations scientifiques.
Ces gamins qui prennent la parole sont
complètement manipulés. Tout à chaque
fois que la jeunesse dans l'histoire a
pris la parole et s'est révolté, on a
toujours dit qu'elle était manipulée.
C'est un une espèce de de light motif
complètement pavlovien de ce que ce que
les jeunes dérangent. Euh
donc euh voilà, c'est très c'est très
caricatural.
On arrive bientôt
à la fin de notre interview. On a pas
posé la question sur la privatisation de
des aéroports de Paris, de la Française
des Jeux. un mot dessus.
Bien, moi je suis contre la
privatisation de l'aéroport de Paris
mais j'ai refusé de signer en fait la le
texte des parlementaires
euh républicains, France insoumise et
cetera parce qu'en fait c'est un texte à
la
au début qui est qui est qui évoque en
fait qui justifie le refus de la
privatisation par la croissance du
trafic aérien qui va être là dans les
prochaines années. Et donc, il faudrait
quand même pas euh que cette man échappe
à l'État et cetera. Et en fait, ça c'est
pas possible en fait. Euh donc moi, je
suis contre la privatisation
pour pouvoir
euh euh au contraire organiser euh une
diminution du trafic aérien, le fait de
ne pas construire le terminal 4, je sais
pas où ça en est d'ailleurs. Euh voilà,
donc pas du tout dans cette
dans cette pour les mêmes arguments en
fait que ceux que ceux qui sont contre.
C'est un bon exemple en fait de ce que
je
de ce qu'est aussi le l'attitude de la
gauche vis-à-vis de l'écologie. En fait,
cette histoire de ce
une écologie de d'opportunisme, c'est
quoi ? Ben en tout cas euh
euh
on peut signer un texte qui avec les
républicains. En soit euh moi je peux
tout à fait signer un texte avec les
républicains.
Avec le Front National aussi
par exemple je l'ai fait
le Rassemblement national
non euh je l'ai fait par exemple contre
la privatisation de l'hydroélectricité.
Donc c'est pas en tant que tel le fait
qu'il y ait des actions transparties. Ça
je suis tout à fait pour. Mais sur quel
contenu en fait sur quelle base
politique ? Et là, le contenu, c'est un
contenu qui est qui est contraire à
l'écologie en fait, de
considérer que
on peut soutenir le une argumentation du
refus de la privatisation basée sur la
croissance du trafic aérien, c'est un
problème. Voilà, c'est un problème pour
prendre un exemple.
Française des jeux,
non, non plus,
non plus.
Non. Euh on va prendre
ça veut pas dire que je je sois par
principe
euh euh pour une espèce de congélation
euh de ce qui est dans le périmètre de
l'État. Euh on peut nationaliser d'un
côté, on peut vendre de l'autre. He je
je suis pas en train de dire pour
l'instant le patrimoine public, il a
plutôt il s'est plutôt effondré hein au
cours des au cours des dernières
décennies et c'est un des problèmes
auquels on est confronté.
On arrive à la fameuse question de fin
qui n'est pas une question, c'est
laisser un conseil. Ah non non, avant
ça, il y a trois bouquins.
Ouais,
faut conseiller trois bouquins. Et
après, c'est laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Alors, trois bouquins.
Oh, trois ou quatre, hein.
Trois ou quatre
euh
que j'ai beaucoup aimé.
Oui.
OK. Euh, bon, le dernier que j'ai
vraiment énormément aimé, c'est les
furtifs de Damasio.
On passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
Ouais.
Euh moi je le connais pas mais
vraiment j'ai vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
aimé ce livre.
Euh
j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi l'arbre monde
de Richard Powerers qui est un livre que
j'ai offert à beaucoup de personnes.
Et puis sinon, je lis énormément de
comment dire de d'essais ou de livres
plus ceux-là sont très politiques en
fait que ce soi les furtifs ou que ce
soit l'arbre monde mais c'est pas que de
la politique, c'est de l'art, c'est de
la littérature, c'est de pour l'un de de
la science-fiction. Donc ouais, je je
resterai sur ces deuxl en fait. Ça ça me
va bien de euh ne pas conseiller
un essai supplémentaire.
Quoi en ce moment ?
En ce moment, je lis l'écologie des
coloniales de Malcomm Ferdinand. C'est
bien, c'est pas bien.
C'est très bien.
Et donc maintenant, un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Dépêchez-vous,
dépêchez-vous
euh de vous engager
euh parce qu'il y a un tic-tac,
mais aussi parce que il faut pas écouter
euh ceux qui sont en train de vous faire
le
une espèce de récit fataliste
euh du on peut rien faire. Voilà, la
raison même de
la politique, c'est de s'organiser
collectivement pour changer le cours de
l'histoire.
Et euh moi je crois pas que le
que nos conditions et nos capacités
d'action aujourd'hui face à
des problèmes d'une magnitude qui sont
sans précédent que l'humanité n'a jamais
connu doivent conduire à se dire euh
qu'on serait dans une situation
euh qui serait la pire qu'on a jamais
rencontré en terme de capacité d'action
de l'espèce humaine. Qu'est-ce que je
veux dire ? c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui un
niveau d'éducation, un niveau
d'information,
des droits d'expression
que bien des luttes et bien des combats
n'avaient pas dans le passé alors qu'ils
ont changé le cours de l'histoire. Donc
moi, je je veux insister là-dessus.
C'est pas une question d'optimisme,
c'est une question d'analyse objective
des faits. Et d'ailleurs le l'émergence
du mouvement actuel de la jeunesse le
prouve qu'on a les outils et les
capacités d'agir et de transformer les
choses.
Delphine Bateau, merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]